I was like, why can't I hear the game?
I always forget that when I play a game on a Switch, I can't
hear it.
Until I switch the...
I was waiting for the music to come back on the game.
I was like, why can't I hear anything?
But if I have...
If I'm on my loading screen, I can't hear the game when I
play Switch.
So I was just sitting there like, when's it going to come
back?
Oops!
Hello everyone, hello everybody.
Is it silent?
No, it's just quiet.
No, you should be able to...
It's like ambiance right now.
Like that.
Just the ambiance at the moment.
Warm and comfy.
Thanks.
I don't feel so good.
good today guys i'm really glad i've had the foresight to
choose this game today so i'm excited to play moon man moon
is like so comfort show right like i there's a 24 hour 24 7
moon man like youtube channel just plays the episodes all
the time and if i'm working sometimes i have it on like If
I'm cleaning, I'll have it on.
Just Moomin all the time.
So I'm really excited.
I've never played any of the Moomin games before.
I know there's a whole bunch of them with like Snuffkin.
But yeah.
Moomin is so nostalgic.
The anime adaptation was one of the earliest anime I ever
watched.
Hope this trip back to Moomin Valley turns out lovely.
I hope so too.
I see you were inspired to go back to Ghostly Bessie by
yesterday's spooky game.
Absolutely.
But yeah, I don't, I, sorry, I'm like so not doing so hot
today.
So if you'll just be patient with me, not like physically,
because I'm a ghost.
Not ectoplasmically, not spiritually.
But yeah.
I'm still also super deep in my move.
I just, when I, when I scheduled this, I was like, this
one's for me.
This is a cozy game for me.
I got, I got, I got dust in my mouth.
Oh, chat's frozen.
Thank you.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I'm watching this while eating a warm apple turnover, which
feels fitting for a stream like this.
Oh my gosh, I wish this game, this game came out like last
month or two months ago.
I wish it had come out later this year.
Because, I mean, it depends on where you are.
It might be starting to be winter if you were in the
southern hemisphere.
But it's actually quite warm.
It's actually quite warm.
But maybe, maybe, you know how some people will, um, some
people will, uh, they'll, they'll, um, what's the word?
Oh, they'll, what, watch scary things in the summer to get
chills and cool themselves down.
Help it!
Let's moving a lot to the MV Strong Later.
Thank you so much for fulfilling my dream of seeing my art
on the stream thumbnail.
random art of you every so often to no abbot i love your art
so much thank you so much for the for the thumbnail art what
the heck you don't have to send a a pink thank you your art
is so cute and it makes me feel so cozy and i've always
wanted to use it for a thumbnail but it's like you have like
the traditional media so it can be a little tough for me but
i was like oh this one be so perfect for movement so thank
you thank you so much it always is it really it really it
really just made me feel so comforted so thank you thank you
cheer up playing some movement role yeah we're movement role
Doctor, I need a way to head pat harder.
Softer, more headpats per head pat.
Turn off my head pat inhibitors.
Holy cow, you are cute.
No, where's the music?
Did it really stop?
Time.
Wow, it had like a nice little soundtrack.
I don't think there's any...
Hold on, let me make sure that there's like subtitles
instead.
stuff.
Use dyslexic font.
Make speech bubbles last longer.
Well, wait, I was just looking for subtitles, but I guess
it's all speech bubbles, huh?
Or...
Snowball fights.
Okay, wait, I'm getting spoiled.
What's a large text?
Oh, yeah, that's for grandma.
That's so many accessibility settings, wow.
Okay, well, We'll just keep Vazas, I guess so.
Dyslexic font.
I don't think I'm dyslexic.
I don't know what's wrong with me, though.
There's something wrong with me, but I'm not sure what.
I don't know.
Is this where he wakes up early from hibernation and can't
fall asleep again?
That would make sense, right?
Little moomans going into hibernation.
you're a vtuber so true looking snug as a bug boys thank you
hmm we're all cozy today for for a movement valley let's
start I suppose sorry if I'm not so entertaining today but
we could be cozy you can use this stream to help wind down
and to maybe sleep or something i'll try and i i what was i
gonna say oh i think you read ahead and accidentally spoon
or what what is that today cozy cozy weekend i hope you guys
are having a good weekend so far um if you're watching this
vod um and maybe Um, hopefully you have a good day.
New game.
Loading.
Also, this game made my Switch go.
I don't know, maybe it's a hefty game.
Nine months, thank you!
Oh, sounds like Minecraft noises.
Moomin
But Moomin mama Why do we have to sleep for so long?
That's the way it's always been with us Moomin trolls When
winter comes along We rest Spoonerism switch around
consonants Which I do too Maybe 60 FPS 4K Moomin
Exactly what the doctor ordered.
Movement Papa.
And when we wake up, spring is back and everything will be
like before.
They're covering things with sheets, just like me.
I'll make you breakfast.
Movement Papa will be getting the house ready, and your best
friend will come back from his winter travels.
I love Snuffkin.
Have you guys ever seen Snuffkin at the Moomin?
The guy that plays Snuffkin at the Moomin theme park?
I have the same reaction to Snuffkin.
Wait, I just realized I'm covering up Moomin.
I don't think there's probably a good place for me to go,
though.
I am Moomin now.
Meem and Snuffkin.
Snuffkin!
Vivikoi, thank you so much for the vibe!
Get it!
But he's such a goof.
I mean, Snuffkin is a goof in general, but he's like a cool
guy.
Oh!
I wish that were me.
Good night, Mumen troll.
I can't unsee Mumen troll anymore.
That's me right there.
spring.
Fabry.
Dreams of warmer days.
Him.
Why is it getting scary?
Oh my gosh.
No, our hibernation.
Snuffkin?
Mm-hmm.
Mum and Mama?
Mum and Papa?
Mm-hmm.
I think this is based off of the movement.
Yeah, the one, the, it was like a couple episodes, wasn't
it?
When he, like, woke up during winter?
Anyone?
I'm just kidding.
New quest.
What's that sound?
Let me, I think maybe it would be better if I move over
here.
I think.
Probably.
Sorry, though.
I'll be looking over this.
way our quest log what's that sound strange sound is coming
from the hallway let's hope it's nothing sinister wait
what's that one really scary guy hmm it's too dark I don't
dare to touch that I should find some sort of light okay
like opening up my curtains.
Oh.
Moo, mint, roll.
The crow!
Oh, he's scary.
Matches.
I'm only supposed to light them when Moo, my mama, or Moo,
my papa is around.
But surely this counts as an emergency.
I mean, though you were so cute.
Thank you, Mr. Yum-Yum.
Strikamach.
Oh.
Wow.
The room.
It's so cute, though.
Huh.
A doorknob.
I should try it on the door.
During hibernation, you are not allowed.
You are not allowed to leave your room.
They literally take the doorknob off your door so that you
are unable to leave.
Why is this so scary?
Mom and mama.
Mom and papa.
Are you awake?
There's like skulls and stuff.
What's that sound?
Grog is my fave.
Kia, I need to keep it in though.
This sick is making my Kia difficult.
Why is this so cute?
Oh my god, there's like evil faces.
Wait, look at this.
There's like one behind me.
Look at that guy.
Oh my gosh.
Why is everything so spooky?
ready for a comforting movement action.
Oh.
That's better.
The hallway looks like it's good old familiar self now.
Like, what was this?
It's just a painting.
Nothing to be scared of.
Right.
And this guy over here.
Terrifying.
Wait, this is actually so bad.
Imagine if the window was left open the entire time.
During hibernation.
The house would be freezing.
No wonder it's so noisy.
The window has blown open.
I should close it.
It's just a skeleton portrait on the wall.
Hmm.
That should do it.
It's still cold, though.
Hmm.
I should check what's going on downstairs.
Why?
I love Moomin lady with the pearl earring.
So cute.
You don't have one of those?
Oh, you think it's one of those optical illusions where I
think it is?
Oh, it is that painting, right?
Where it's the trees, but it looks like a skull from far
away.
I can't explain this one, though.
This guy is just freaky.
This bush.
Wait, there's gotta be something in here.
No?
It's just a painting.
Nothing to be scared of.
Evil bush.
Evil plant.
Oh.
More matches, please.
Another window?
Oh my god, no, they're freezing!
Woman mama, woman papa, rise and shine!
No, not yet.
Full shrubbery.
I'll get this guy a CPAP machine.
Shaking the whole bed.
Oh man, can't you see it's night?
He's shaking.
Hmm.
Hanks you.
The other windows are probably open as well.
No wonder it's freezing.
Hmm.
No wonder who opened them.
Movement row.
A creeping cold house.
Close all the windows.
Oh!
What just happened?
Did I fall?
Oh!
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, maybe I need to stay out of the way of the wind.
That's better.
Still cold, duh.
Did they block the door?
is blocked.
The wind must have knocked the shelf over.
Chantala Green!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the Super Chat.
I'm seeing if there's any other interactables.
Hmm.
The wind must have knocked over the shelf.
Oh my god, it destroyed everything.
Oh no, Mum and Mama's precious face!
The wind must have knocked it over.
I should find all the pieces before she wakes up.
New quest?
Sound 25!
Oh, uh, we're just lighting up the room while they're
asleep, no big deal.
What does a piece look like?
I mean, surely they would all be in this room, no?
Because that's how a broken vase would be?
This is kind of scary.
I shouldn't expect a scary game at all.
Oh, Mom and Papa.
It's such a cute game, though.
At the same time.
The wind blew them all away.
Yeah.
Why would we go in here?
Wait, I think I found a piece.
Me!
Did nobody lock the windows?
Oh my gosh.
Moomin!
I don't know if we can... There we go.
That should be the last one.
Sniffle, sniffle.
Cough, cough.
Who's coughing?
Papa?
Poor Moomin, Papa!
I might catch the Moomin!
No!
That he's gonna moon and die!
Wait, if we catch the moon and flew in hibernation.
The basement furnace, I should check if it's on.
Oh, if only it wasn't in the basement.
Oh, to the basement.
Grab that.
Oh, here's a piece of moon and mama's precious vase.
Did I say vase or vase?
Are you fancy?
Are you?
Minto.
I'm Minto.
Voise.
Vice.
Oh.
Let's see, is there a...
Oh, there is a light in here.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
That window won't...
Oh, there's a basement.
What strong winds?
This place is a mess.
For real, though.
You feel cooler if you say vase.
That's true.
Oh, my goodness.
Just a few embers left.
I need more firewood.
Woman Papa usually leaves some laying around here.
Oh, it's so dark down here.
I need some light to find it.
Oh, uh, one.
Wait.
One out of five.
Two?
Yes.
Thank you.
I don't need to open my inventory.
It's so scary.
Wait, just a box?
Hmm.
The long dark looks different than I remember.
Is this the last one?
Yeah!
The game is just spooky enough, you know, to kind of unnerve
you a little bit.
You're like, ooh.
Like the music even, just like the...
There.
That should warm things up.
What's that sound?
Woman mama, are you awake?
Huh.
She's probably making me breakfast.
Can't say I was expecting this.
We neither.
It's actually so spooky.
Antics in the attic.
Nanda Tom.
Woman mama's jam.
here follow the drips the drip oh they stop here
they're still sleeping and who made the noise tags are
family-friendly casual cozy whoa brother thank you so much
brother 50 gifts in thank you so so much thank you who was
born
It's coming from upstairs.
Ah, gulp.
Hey, yeah.
Gosh.
Bronson, oh my gosh, thank you for another 50.
Thank you.
Eek!
The ladder fell down.
Is someone up there?
Why is this so terrible?
A dragon.
Oh.
A squirrel!
It
was just a squirrel.
I must have scared it.
I should see if it's alright.
Jumped out like the two-story, three-story window.
I don't know about that guy.
A squirrel-squarely guest.
What's this?
Oh, another.
Nice.
Another piece.
He's dead.
No, he's not.
He got...
He fell onto the fluffy, fluffy marshmallow snow.
It went out through the window.
I've never been outside alone in the night time before.
Certainly not in the cold.
What about the poor squirrel?
Come on, Mumen troll.
Nothing to worry about.
It's just the great outdoors.
Hmm.
Here goes...
Nothing.
Beautiful.
He froze to death.
Don't they hibernate too?
Oh my gosh, the house is buried.
What's this?
What's this happened?
This must be snow.
Woman mama has told me about this.
Is movement not cold?
Everything is so cold and colorless.
It's like the whole world died while I slept.
squirrels close to me because it started raining on my walk.
After I took pictures of them, my umbrella broke!
No, it didn't mean!
It's kind of worth it, though.
I've been watching so many videos of people that set up
boxes for squirrels, and they live there.
And did you know that when they greet each other, they come
back home to the box, they kiss each other.
They grab each other's faces and they go, and then they are
so cute when they're relaxing because they like are they're
just starfish on they become so relaxed they like cuddle
with each other but they also like just lay flat out
it's so cute oh it's it's so stinking cute
on each other's faces and they and then they they and it's
so cute too because like the guy who made the one specific
guy that i've been watching who made the one box like
sometimes it'll get taken over by bees and so he has to go
in and rescue them because the bees are trying to take over
the box and he's like no this is for the squirrels and then
sometimes a rival squirrel will come in and be like, he'll
be like, this is my box now, and then the owner of the box
will be like, no!
And it's literally like a cartoon.
Like, you know how when, in old cartoons, when things are
running so fast, they're like bouncing off the walls and you
can, they're like, that SpongeBob, like, you want to see me
run to that rock and back?
You want to see me do it again?
It's literally that.
They're like,
fighting each other bouncing off the walls in this teeny
tiny box.
Wait, hold on.
I'll download the TikTok, and if I remember to show you guys
later, I'll show you.
Hopefully I can download it.
Sometimes you can, sometimes you can't.
Hold on.
I watched it just the other day.
Oh, here we go.
So cute.
Wait, no.
It won't let me.
And no, it won't let me download it!
No!
Oh, they're so cute though.
I could screen record it maybe.
Can you tell us the username?
Oh, true.
GeoBeats underscore...
Wait, underscore stories.
And it's called...
Wait, at...
Wait, I think they took it from this guy, but they credit
him.
I don't know if they ask or not.
I was like, hold on.
Wait, I have to show you these score.
Oh my god, they're so passionate.
When they kiss, it's like...
It's like...
It rivals a romance novel, like...
Hold on.
It's like someone saw the world and went, Curse of Raw.
No!
Wait, where's my...
Where did I upload this picture to?
Uh-oh.
Oh, I uploaded it to the Densetsu Discord.
Oopsie!
I uploaded this photo to the Discord.
Why do you have that?
No, this is from the TikTok that I was just talking about.
This is from the, this is how the squirrels greet each
other.
Since I told you, it's so passionate.
Someone play Careless Whisker.
So yeah, that's how the squirrels, they greet each other and
they live in this little box.
And they live there for generations.
Like, the babies of the babies and the babies and the babies
and the babies will all live there together.
and it's so sweet.
Caption it with us and see what the others think.
It's a demo touch intensifies.
Because every time we touch, I feel the kind of...
Spreading the love without context, but it's okay the world
needs more love.
Anyway.
Oh, there's a squirrel in this game.
Everything is so cold and colorless.
It's like the whole world died while I slept.
Oh, there he is.
There he goes.
I saw him.
He rolled.
The squirrel went that way.
It must be freezing cold, poor thing.
Wow, look.
I can draw in the...
Hold on.
Draw eye blue.
I'm doing it.
Oh, no.
I messed up.
I don't know how to do your mouth, though.
You can kind of see it.
My home is frozen with icicles.
These icy spikes look dangerous.
In their defense, everything dies.
Wait, does that mean we can't go back inside?
Because we can't...
Oh, I'm in the snow.
I want to keep exploring the snowy snow terrain.
How is it this cold yet the water isn't completely frozen
over?
You know?
Oh, there he is.
Little Squale!
There you are.
I thought this was my house.
I just wanted to warm myself.
Then I remembered, I don't have a house.
Sorry!
Oh no, he has no squirrel box!
There he goes.
But I thought, again, I thought they hibernated.
Please stay, come and warm yourself!
Oh.
Poor thing, it must be so cold.
What about us?
We don't even have shoes on.
No one to kiss.
The weather is getting worse.
How can anything survive out here?
I don't.
That's why you hide, René.
Oh my goodness, it's all blocked off.
Let's follow him.
This little tiny steps.
Oh.
The music is so creepy, though.
Oh my gosh, it's getting hard to see.
Please, Mr. Squire!
This is Squale!
I didn't mean to scare you!
Uh-oh.
My screen is starting to freeze up!
Will this help?
Ugh, it's so cold.
Come, come, come, come, come, come!
Oh.
It goes out immediately now.
No, I think we're in trouble.
Uh, hello lady, are you freezing too?
Let me rest just for...
No!
Don't fall asleep in the snow!
Lady?
Is there anyone else there?
Oh.
The wind is too strong.
This way.
So, very cold.
I can't
get over here.
There must be another way.
Oh my gosh.
It's like...
I'm really freezing up on my... on my screen.
Whoa!
Eek!
Uh, this way?
Oh my god!
No, no!
Wake up, little friend!
This is all my fault!
He's fine, he's fine.
He just needs a hug.
Oh my god, he's frozen solid!
No!
He's a place further than the boom in verse.
It's stuck.
I can't get it loose.
It's...
The rigor mortis is already set up.
You know what?
This is reminding me of.
It's reminding me of when I played that.
What was that game?
Uh...
Aren't you immune to cold?
I saw Skippity Mint at a con...
What?
What do you mean?
No, not Faith.
Um...
Oh my goodness.
Madagascar!
I played the demo of the Madagascar game on...
On...
I was trying to remember what country it was.
on a demo disc and when you would like launch the score it's
just it was a pile of their little dead score of bodies
it was so tragic it was just a it was just a battle I think
about that quite often.
I think that was like maybe one of the hardest times I've
ever laughed at a video game.
I'm so funny.
Oh, I recommend it.
That stream.
Too ticky!
You're awake as well!
Come now, little moment troll.
This is no weather for summer creatures.
Huh?
But... the squirrel!
Uh...
It's too late!
Follow me into the bathing house.
No!
Night of the Lemur Massacre.
Never forget!
I didn't think this game would have squail death.
Aww.
There.
You're safe.
The squail!
We have to go back for him!
Hmm.
When the storm passes, it'll be too late.
For sure.
Do you think it's still alive?
This is so tragic.
No, not in this weather.
This is so sad.
No.
I tried to save it, but I failed.
I really tried to.
Too ticky.
Wait, what was the lady that he saw then?
Was it the witch?
Now it's gone and it's my fault.
Uh-huh.
Uh-huh?
He's trying to say no, but the voice said, uh-huh.
Hogwash.
You did everything you could to prevent it from happening.
If movement hovernaid during the winter, then why did they
have perfect?
snow camouflage right sadly sometimes that's not enough how
can you be so calm about this hmm death is part of life the
lady of the cold gives and takes hmm the lady of the cold
who is she hmm Every year the Lady of the Cold comes down
from the frosty north.
Tucking Mumen Valley into her snowy blanket, putting it to
sleep, letting the roots dream of their rebirth.
We hate the Lady of the Cold.
So the Lady of the Cold is the reason Mumen Papa, Mumen Mama
and Mumen Papa are sleeping?
And why Snuffkin left?
Tootiki's outfit was traditional Finnish clothing back then.
That's so cute.
It's a bit more complicated than that.
Finnish Yukiyona.
You hear that?
The winds are calming down.
It's safe to go outside now.
Safer at least.
Here, take this scarf.
It will guard you from winter's sharpest bite.
Uh-huh.
Remember, this is why you need to pay attention during a
conversation, not just say a hot word.
the other person says.
Wait, stop hogging the blankets share.
What do you mean?
You are quite cozy right on top of my head, no?
Thanks too, Tiki.
Check on the squirrel.
I'm glad Moomin has great priorities.
The squirrel...
God?
Did the lady of the cold take it?
Quite possibly.
or perhaps it got away.
Hmm?
Well, which one is it?
Okay, Vuban.
I need to know.
My goodness.
Put away the fists.
Vuban's about Vuban's about to throw hands.
Poor Tootiky is just trying to explain.
Brandon, thank you.
I hope you're well too.
Then let's go with the option that gives you the most hope.
Smells like ghost dandruff.
I don't have dandruff.
That's your dandruff.
I want to go home.
Aww.
Seems like the storms have made it.
that a bit difficult.
Oh, moving.
The soundtrack is too good.
You could probably remove those icicles with a snowball or
two.
Snowball?
The snow is so cold to the touch.
There's a pair of mittens in the bathing house.
Somewhere.
If you find them, I can teach you to throw a proper
snowball.
exciting look for mittens this is where he lied who made
this when did you have the time hold on I'm exploring now oh
wait that's not him right I sure hope that's not the spoil
smells like mint and happiness yeah exactly my head smells
like a fresh shampoo
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
wait, can we go into the water?
Swim?
No.
Mm-mm.
I'm so fast and I'm so furious, because I don't know where
that squiggle went.
I'm about to punch too, Taku.
Oh, wee-wee-wee.
That was so fun.
Cloud, welcome back.
Thank you!
No mittens here.
In here.
Who was that?
A troll?
Hey, come back with the mittens!
This guy's standing in the closet.
Oh, nice.
Anything else in here?
I must get the mittens from that...
thing!
I'm not good at remembering the names of all the critters
and stuff in Momin.
Their name.
Thank you.
Mom.
Please, I need those mittens!
No, please!
I promise I won't hurt you.
Oh, I dropped the mittens.
Where'd I die, I'm so?
Oh.
Oh, I can use either the...
Oh, that's fine.
So, I have tools now.
I can't do both.
It's dangerous to light a match and hold the mittens.
Your hands will catch fire.
Who was that fellow?
Hmm.
I see you.
made an acquaintance with the ancestor.
Your ancestor, to be precise.
My ancestor?
I have so many questions.
Actually, never mind.
I just want to get home.
Can you knock the hat off of the snowman?
I will try.
Very well.
Do you see those icicles there?
Try packing a hard snowball with your new mittens.
And throw it right at them.
Hmm.
I've never thrown a snowball before.
Can't you do it?
Nonsense.
You're more capable than you think.
Okay.
When the snow covered grass...
How do I throw it now?
Oh.
Oh, I killed him.
Oh my god.
I didn't just knock the...
I'm a murderer.
I didn't...
I didn't just...
Oh my god, I'm a murderer.
Oh my goodness.
I'm trying to get the... like this.
Take it.
Oh, okay, it doesn't do anything.
Wait, what about the bird's nest?
I've taken one life, what's another one?
Hey, wake up birds!
Wake up, birds!
Okay.
Wee!
No birds inside.
No birds in sight.
Nothing here, right?
Nothing here.
No one hiding?
Wait, that looks like I can knock it over, no.
No, no, no.
Uh, maybe I have to...
Let go...
Hmm...
Maybe like up here?
On this rock?
No.
It might need to be pushed later instead.
So I guess if I can hit something, it will aim at it for me.
But if I can't...
Or, I mean, but I did it with the...
I'm so sorry, Snowman!
I'm the one!
worst on the worst wait can i
well aimed
oh now they give me the tutorial sorry too ticky
wait is too ticky a girl such a cute name there you go you
should be able to make your way home now be safe i'll check
up on you later I'll probably be sound asleep then, but
thank you.
Why did Booman age 50 years?
I don't remember her in the show.
Way to cross.
And those icy things seem dangerous.
I wonder if I can get them down.
And it'll make a little bridge.
Oh, nice.
La la la.
On my way back home.
There's gotta be something in that little thing, though.
I see it.
Wait.
Oh.
The music is so cute.
I think there's a little...
There's a little thing there, right?
Maybe it's a cat...
Oh, is it a candle?
Wait, so if I...
Wait, how do I...
There we go.
Oh, it is!
Oh cute!
Wait.
Huh?
Stupid winter.
Stupid everything.
I'm the worst evil last.
I hope that Squail made it.
Hoping doesn't change anything.
I'm really trying to stick out too ticky.
I'm sorry to suspect Moomin may have issues.
Moomin can't help his his psychopathic tendencies.
Wait, I see that there's like an up.
Oh, I think that's the way we went around.
We'll make this.
I think I remember doing that before.
Woman says, screw everything!
I hate winter!
I hate it all!
Wait, no, maybe... but it shows my pathway.
Hmm.
Did I just go this way?
So cute.
My home.
It's so buried in snow.
Why did I ever get out of bed?
Yeah, but you saved your family too.
I don't understand what the Lady of the Cold wants.
I don't want to understand.
Because of them.
I just want everything to be green and friendly again.
The windows were...
open so we saved them I know I just did that but I was
making sure there wasn't anything on this side and there was
not I don't have anything to chop this tree with oh why did
I get out of bed why the bathing house is this way yeah The
Moomin family would have frozen to death if Moomin hadn't
gotten out of bed.
And so, so selfishly, not selfish, selflessly closed all the
windows and protected the home.
Hmm.
When I wake up, I want to play in the river again.
I want to smell the flowers and I want to forget all about
today.
Poor Moomin is traumatized.
One down.
Two more to go.
I turned my AC up for this.
Back to bed.
Game over.
Another game.
In my...
Ancestor!
What are you doing here?
Don't hurt my parents, do you hear me?
Huh?
You don't seem too hostile.
Maybe even friendly?
This is a shaggy guy.
Perhaps a bit cold, though, are you?
So, you probably came here for warmth, just like the
squirrel.
I'm sorry if I scared you.
We can share the house.
It's nicer with...
Family.
Now let's sleep until better times.
Both of us.
Good night.
Good night, world.
This has been like a bad dream.
I'll go back to sleep.
Woman has once again aged 50 years.
Good night, everybody.
There.
Go to sleep now, Momentrol.
I don't seem to be able to.
Oh, that's the worst.
I'll just lay here.
How far away is summer?
Hours?
Days?
More days?
He needs a kiss from...
Woman, mama?
Who's there?
Has the lady of the cold come for me?
Or perhaps something less dramatic.
Let's hope for the latter.
A visitor?
How exciting.
and scary it's the squirrel it's him, I know it I sense it I
sense it what are you doing I see you found your place
he's chilling Hello.
I like how he left the lights on and everything.
The ancestor.
I would be also afraid of a fire happening.
Oh.
Good.
You're up.
The outside looks less scary today.
Did something change?
Uh-huh.
Something is always changing.
Wow.
that's so deep the ancestor is wise he's just a chill little
guy something is always changing my goodness to take it hmm
are you looking for the ancestor he seems content here by
the fireplace like winter doesn't worry him at all hmm the
ancestor has been around for a while he has seen it all
before on that note there's something i need to show you
there's a bonfire site east of here meet me there here i've
marked it on this map for you hi tuk tiki i wonder what she
wants to show me i better get to the bonfire site a knock at
dawn it looks less scary because the sun came up?
Interesting.
I wonder what Tutiki wants to show me.
She said to meet her in the forest.
I better get going.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Oh.
How did Tutiki get across?
Oh, dang it.
This is the way to the bonfire site.
How are you liking the game?
It's so cozy.
Wait!
Yeah!
Wait, am I going there right away?
Yeah, right?
She jumped like the mad woman that she is.
Outside in that blizzard with just the, with a t-shirt on.
Tootiki is crazy.
Oh!
Help!
Don't hurt me!
Here!
Winter being.
Be scared.
Wait.
Are you afraid of me?
Then why'd you come chasing at me?
That doesn't make any sense.
I'm the least scary being in all of Moomin Valley.
I...
Oh, yeah.
I'm sorry.
I don't understand your accent.
I'm Moomintroll.
Or Moomintroll.
Moomintroll.
Eek, says the bird slayer.
You mean me troll.
Wait, you guys can't see it.
I'm blocking him.
Troll.
I'll scoot over a little bit more.
Well.
Yes, I am a Mumen troll.
I'm not scary.
We read troll.
We read scary.
We read...
I thought the same of you, but I guess we are more alike
than I first.
thought who are you oh movement roll talk making me want to
buy a roll cake oh that sounds so good me too we we we we we
we we we self huh me me friend oh oh we we we friend of me
we
and legs.
I'll give an offer.
Okay, good.
Sharing is caring, everybody.
I want something sweet today, but I had Snickers ice cream.
Oh, this must be the place!
I still want something sweet.
You ever have something sweet and then you want more sweet?
The sweet was not like...
Shifty eyes over here.
Wee-wee-wee-wee-wee.
Wee-wee hallowe.
Halloween-wee-wee.
Halloween-wee sorrow.
Halloween-wee-wee sorrow.
Oh no, I think he's hungry.
Hello.
Mm-hmm.
I know this place.
It's very different in winter though.
Everything is.
I remember celebrating summer solstice here with Mum and
Mama and Mum and Papa.
Every year for a thousand years, the winter beings emerge on
the darkest day to celebrate.
Are they coming out?
By lighting the grave winter bond.
fire wait they look like the poem poke points right what are
those called
it's a not a cult it's not a cult this marks the turning of
the seasons and the departure of the lady of the cold pata
pata potapone yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
allowing for spring to return to Mumen Valley.
This year, however, the winter beings are strangely absent,
lest the bonfire has not been lit.
Why has something happened?
The music in this is so soft.
I don't know.
Perhaps it is the harsh winter storms preventing them.
them, trapped in ice and distressed.
Maybe there are more.
Did the lady of the cold do this?
How cruel!
This game makes me want to curl up into a little ball and
stews.
I hate the lady of the cold.
The lady is neither cruel nor forgiving.
She just is.
Hmm.
Somebody should do something!
So the winter beings can light the bonfire and complete the
tradition.
Oh.
Someone should do something.
Anyway, Moomin, I'm cold.
Who?
Moomin, Mama and Moomin, Papa are asleep.
And Snuffkin is away and...
We must toss snowball to her.
Uh-huh.
at me like that.
Oh!
Seems like it is up to us, young Mumen Troll.
Huh?
If you come across any winter beings, see if they need your
help.
All they know how to say is wee wee though.
Also, if you want to see the bonfire lit, perhaps you should
look for more participants.
Not everyone in Mumen Valley is asleep.
Minto destroyed the bird with eyes, so imagine aiming her
with fire.
I didn't destroy any bars with eyes.
What do you mean?
There were none.
Go see Philly Junk.
I saw her fretting about her home recently.
And we should find someone to play music.
If only Snuffkin were here.
We will be needing firewood for the bonfire as well.
A lot of firewood.
Okay, so we gotta get firewood.
And we got to invite guests.
And we got to go to Philly Junk's house.
Okay, so we need to chop the tree.
So I imagine we'll probably be given like a...
Um, an axe.
And my axe.
Be hell smooth.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
We need so much wood.
Oh, hey.
Wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee wee.
Are you lost?
Wee wee dark wee wee.
He wants me to light the pole.
You made those words up, Mint.
What words?
Mathetes welcome back to.
Thank you.
Wee wee troll make wee wee lie.
Oh.
Are you afraid of the dark?
Ie.
Weewee self-brave wee wee why does he look like holy cow
My guy is traumatized,
too Weewee friend scared Oh, so your friend is afraid of the
dark Path weewee dark wee wee scare friend Weewee path light
friend come wee wee If I see some torches around, I'll light
them for you.
Ha.
I mean, for your friend, of course.
He's seen some.
Yeah, he's seen some stuff.
There's a torch right there.
There you go, friend.
That's one.
Let me see if I can find some more.
Oh, I can't.
No, I can't.
Get this.
Wait, so we're trying to get to...
Okay.
Do you need help?
Oh, you're hungry, right?
Hi, how are you feeling?
Oh.
We empty inside.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wee, wee, empty inside.
Wee, wee, hollow, wee, wee.
Oh, that sounds horrible.
I don't know if I can help, but I'll sure try.
Would you like to talk about your feelings?
Do you miss your parents?
Oh, no, wee, wee talk.
Wee, wee eat.
So, the hollowness you're feeling is...
Hunger?
Wee.
Self.
Hungry.
Wee.
Empty inside.
The divorce.
Wee.
Took the kids.
No.
It's been a tough wee.
Wee winter for this guy.
Wee.
Food fill.
Self.
Wee.
Well, I know exactly how you feel.
That's one problem I do think I can fix.
Hang around here and I'll look for something to eat.
Okay.
So we gotta light the things.
Chop the wood.
Light the torches.
We have so much we're doing.
I'm like the busiest movement troll ever now.
What's up here?
Oh, no, no.
I am not going that way.
They're growling at me.
I'm right.
Philly Junk Awaken Winter?
Whatever for.
Philly Junk lives west of here.
I should go check on her.
The music stopped too.
Yeah, freaky.
Oh.
La la la.
Philly Junk, huh?
She lives just across the bridge.
Oh, hello, friend.
what is your what do you desire no we we find we we gone
self we we gone what's wrong hello you're a rather small
winter being are you lost no we we we self hide we we good
self good we we shouldn't you be with the other winter
beings are you on your own We, we, we find self.
Oh.
He's on a self.
Oh, he's playing hide and seek.
I think they're playing hide and seek.
Oops.
I'm high.
Okay.
Time to kill the whole family.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, there's...
When did these snowmen get here?
I'm taking out the bloodline.
Gosh, Moomin's aim is crazy, though.
Village arc.
Call me Itachi.
Wait, where'd he go, though?
For real.
Maybe you think he went past this thing?
No survivors.
Oh, oh, what's happening?
How can I get the Philly Junk with all the snow blocking
away?
Oh, yeah.
I know.
Mum and Mama usually keeps a shovel in her garden.
Oh, okay.
Oh, is that who I think it is?
Ah!
Look who finally decided to wake up.
Little Mai!
How wonderful to see you.
How can I miss out on this?
Winter is great.
Is anyone else around?
Mum and Mama and Mum and Papa are sleeping.
Stuffkin is gone.
Why does he talk like he's dead?
Well, we can play together then.
Oh, I'm actually on my way to invite Phil.
drunk to the great winter bonfire they're all they're all
perhaps you would like to join me as well i'm bringing
spring back oh spring whatever for winter is so much fun so
many activities let's play a game movement troll it will
help you unwind what do we how did you do that so fast
it certainly used to be oh my god she stole it oh my
goodness oh she's so fast
am i trying to get you or hey give me that shovel right now
i'll play you for it the rules are simple defeat me in a
snowball fight and i might give you the shovel back.
Might.
I really need a shovel to get that belly junk.
Our first boss battle, you guys.
I'm seething right now.
I need that.
Vanguard!
Oh, dang.
Take that!
Oh, she's got one.
She's got one.
She's running.
Take that!
Two strikes!
Hooray!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, dang it.
She got me.
Yeah.
One more.
Wait, I can get her.
Easy.
Thank you for the fun and games.
Thank you for the fun and games, little my.
Now let's bring spring back.
First we need to find Philly junk.
So many activities!
She's such...
Moving out of the shovel!
You say I can get the filly jug now.
So people just go inside the houses and take everything.
I love her so much too.
She's such a goofy.
...
so funny i'm shoveling every day i'm shoveling
she's such a being i love it
so am i your favorite yes i like her i really like snuffkin
too though
this away i'm shoveling dang Woman's a beast.
I mean, yes, but...
I like the music so much.
Woodpecker?
Huh.
Billy Dog's house is this way.
This reminds me...
A long time ago, a maid cafe when I was just...
You know, when I was a small, small ghost.
the first mint cafe that I haunted this winter has been
nothing short of horrible um there was there was a chimney
and I'm not ready to part with the my dear heirlooms and a
woodpecker would come sometimes and like knock on the
chimney and it would be like movement members watchalongs I
would love that we can just turn on the 24-7 channel and
watch It would be so loud because of the echo of like the...
Of the...
Of the chimney.
So he'd go crazy on it.
I know, Moomin is so strong.
Snow problem, he says.
Nice.
I cleared all that out for you.
Philly donk, how wonderful to see you.
Would you like to...
Wonderful?
Can't you say I'm in distress?
Yeah, Moonpecker machine gun at 6 a.m.
That's quite literally what it was like.
My children went inside to look for our precious fair...
And my old house in Moonpecker would hit the wall.
wall over my bed every spring.
I had to train it every year to stop.
Family air.
Airlooms.
Then all the snow and ice came crashing down.
The house is a death trap.
No one can get in or out.
And now the airlooms are lost forever.
What about your children?
Oh,
and the children, obviously.
I guess I could help you.
What do you mean, I guess, movement?
The children are going to die.
Could you go into the death trap for me?
Oh, how kind.
He'll be fine.
Probably.
A couple of snowballs should take care of the icicles.
And that snow is no match for Moomin Mama's shovel.
If you break anything, you're paying for it.
This ain't about them.
Yeah, for real.
This game is so goofy.
Hello, hello.
Help!
This is them!
Mother!
She doesn't care about you, kids.
She doesn't care about you.
Incredible voice acting.
Oh, we did it.
That was it.
Claire, everyone is in the clear.
My dear children, you are alive.
It's okay, you can break anything.
We'll pay for it.
Okay, I'll let them know, Spank.
Thank you.
It's too dangerous to go back inside and too cold to stay
outside.
The whole world is unsafe.
You can come live in the movement house if you want.
It's not much, but it's safe.
Woman, mama, and woman, papa are sleeping.
It would be nice to have someone around.
Yes, I suppose.
A bit messy, usually, but you could probably fix that.
Am I going to get a thanks at all or anything?
By the way, you wouldn't happen to have any leftover
firewood.
Do we get the axe now?
I need all I've got inside the house.
Who knows how long the lady of the cold will stay.
However, you're welcome to anything you find under the snow
in the garden.
look there.
Shovel some snow.
Remove the dead trees you come over.
There might even be some firewood stuck up in the trees.
Why would they do that?
So if I clean up your garden to get, I get to keep the dead
trees?
Yes.
You're welcome.
I don't think we should have invited this lady into our
home.
Can I go in?
The winter has really taken a toll on Philly Junk's
prize-worthy garden.
What a character.
I know.
I can't wait for all the snow to melt away.
Beast, beast, beast, beast.
Oh!
I found my first firewood.
One out of 125.
Yeah, more like Philly jerk.
So true.
Oh!
Yeah, only a few of them.
have to go we'll definitely get it you know after i put this
game on my schedule i was like i wonder like how long of a
game it is philly junk said i could keep anything i find
yeah um maybe i'll find some treasures i doubt philly junk
would bury any of her precious belongings um it's it's like
a it said it's like a seven hour game Four to five hours?
Oh, have you guys played it?
Let me in.
Let me in for that sweet, sweet.
Yeah, Google said like six to eight hours, yeah.
I guess I get your money's worth.
Where else can I go and dig?
acts like so bad to do anything.
Oh, I forgot about the shortcut.
Oops.
I consulted how long to beat is this four hours.
Oh, okay.
Maybe we will beat it today then.
Oh, wait.
More snow.
I will rid the world of snow.
I'm like digging it, but where does it go?
I found something.
A firewood.
Nice.
Snow, snow.
We need more snow.
Indeed.
Oh, this goes someplace.
There's so many places to explore.
That's fun.
Oh yeah, we're on a roll now, baby.
Whose cave is this?
It's probably gonna be really scary in here.
There always it.
Now they think about it.
We're playing Minecraft now?
It's my cave now.
Yeah, baby.
What is this?
Hmm.
I don't have anything to break this ice with.
What's this way?
Oh, more ice to break.
How did my mom's face get all the way into the cave?
The Lady of the Cold.
She's such a cruel mistress.
Why did she take my mom's...
Why did she take my mom's vase?
Throw it everywhere.
I see a board down there.
Let's go.
What's in here?
Something.
Something shiny.
Oh, I see creepy eyes.
She was jealous.
Yeah, I think so.
How do I get in there?
Wait, maybe if I...
Oh, there we go.
Longer lasting matches.
Looks like some kind of lamp oil.
Oh, nice!
It can carry an internal flame.
Maybe Tuteki knows about it.
Huge!
What is this?
Oh, wood.
Nice.
What's that guy doing down here?
He's sparkling.
I imagine we'll be able to break these open eventually too.
So we can come back here for stuff.
I don't think the matches will work on the ice though.
We'll try.
Maybe just a tad too little fire.
Yeah.
Just a tad too little fire.
I want to play Minecraft.
I want to play Hytale.
More power.
Once we become stronger.
If they last longer than four hours, it'll be reductor.
Bow!
Oh!
Hello, do I take it?
I found this lamp oil in the caves.
Do you think it could be useful?
Hmm.
Let me see.
I think so.
Hand over your matches.
I'll try to make them more durable.
She's crafting.
God, I wish that were me.
There you go.
Your matches should have lasted a lot longer now.
There's upgrades in this game.
It's crazy.
Thank you.
Wait, you think I can dig this thing?
No, it won't let me.
No, but it looks so diggable.
Ouch, hold on.
I took out one of my headphones.
There's so much wood here.
Wait, wasn't there something over here that I...
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's an... I see.
There's something we want to dig there.
Are my ears okay?
starting to hurt just a little bit.
Oh, there's here too.
There's something in here.
I can feel it in my bones.
There's something in there.
There's nothing in here.
And then I guess we'll...
Oh!
No, take that.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, no, no, take that.
Take that.
There we go.
Nice, nice.
I thought you don't have bones.
Well, maybe that's why I didn't feel anything.
Oh, a friend.
Hello.
Huh.
What are you looking at?
The sea?
Wee-wee family letter.
Wee-wee.
Wee.
Letter gone.
Wee-wee.
Ew.
Wee-wee family gone.
Wee-wee.
A letter from your family?
Missing?
I'm sure your family's all right.
Let me help you find the letter.
Wee-wee, letter-wee, bottle-wee-wee.
Okay.
Bottlegon, wee.
Family gone, wee.
What is that behind the thing?
I need an axe.
Where else can we go?
Went to the cave.
I guess we have the shovel now, so we'll just try and find
more places we can go to by shoveling ourselves out of it,
right?
There was a bit more deep snow on the lower left.
Oh, a fully drunk sound.
Oh, thank you.
I must have missed it.
Thank you so much.
I missed it with my eyes.
How could I...
Wait, there's some more here too.
This might be an entrance to something.
Or a wood.
No entrance.
Just wood.
Keep your eyes peeled, everybody, for...
Crazy amounts of snow.
Lower level.
Did we go down here?
Oh, this is the wood blocking our path.
Woo, woo, woo.
It's that dove.
The morning dove.
Aye, aye.
Everybody's eyes are peeled.
I blink one eye at a time, so I always have one eye open.
Wait, this one?
It wouldn't let me shovel that.
I tried pressing it.
Oh, here!
There we go.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, I missed such a huge area.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Woman so strong It can shovel from beyond the fence Are
those graves?
Yeah, the logs are flashing Because we're able to cut them
But we don't have an axe yet Are these graves?
Oh, nope
Okay, nice We got some more wood Oh, wait Oh, there's some
more here too.
Wait, I got this before, didn't I?
No, I don't think I don't.
Oh, a single piece amongst all of this.
It would have been very unfortunate.
It wouldn't be on par for what we've experienced so far
though.
It wouldn't be so different.
There must be more snow around that we can shovel.
Eepie, binky.
Yeah, I am a little bit.
I was, I've been packing all day.
I originally was going to have my stuff out by yesterday.
But I had to, I had to change some stuff around.
I had to and so now it will be picked up next week so but
luckily I've been able to kind of chill a little bit on the
um on the packing but I mean I'm obviously not too chill but
um
oh yeah let's see what this is our mail oh there's a letter
in here Sleep well.
Your first warm spring day, you'll have me here again.
Snuffkin?
It's from Snuffkin.
I really miss him.
I miss him too.
We're gonna get a whole game without him.
That's so sad.
Uh-oh.
They can't get inside.
You said it was safe.
The whole place is a danger to our world.
This pile of snow came crashing down right before you
arrived.
Trying to finish what it started with my heirlooms and my
children.
Please note the order.
Airlooms first, children second.
What are the heirlooms?
I'm sorry, I'll remove the snow right away.
Out of the frying pan, into the fire, except it's the cold.
There, save it last.
Let's go inside, children.
Anything is better than this cold.
Everybody's gonna be making a noise.
Such a racket in our home while my parents are sleeping.
Mum and Papa and Mama are just trying to catch some Z's and
everyone's like, She is so rude.
I see you've got your figurines up.
Oh, these heirlooms.
Yes, this place is starting to feel more like my home
already.
Okay, but it's not.
It's my home.
This is what I was afraid of.
I was afraid that she was going to try and take over.
Inner peace starts with total control of your external
environment.
Children.
Total control!
No, Mumen, it's not...
It's not wonderful!
I've heard some people call mozzarella Mumen meat.
That's terrible!
I would become vegetarian if, oh, you could only eat Mumen.
Now that you're settled, I was hoping I could invite you to
the great winter bu- Shh!
Everybody stay quiet.
The smallest vibration might disrupt this figurine
arrangement I've worked so hard for.
Look, mother, a strange dog!
That's my grandpa.
Yeah, kill it.
Yeah, good job, grandpa.
The heirlooms!
Eek!
My whole arrangement destroyed by that thing!
And it ran away with the porcelain cat, my most precious
heirloom.
Don't just stand around.
Bring it back.
Hmm.
Yes, mother.
Help!
Hmm.
That doesn't sound good.
Oh my god, he just said help.
What is going on?
I can't believe this is happening.
Don't just stand around.
Go after them.
Hmm.
What is happening?
No, she only has two children and no heirlooms.
The precious kitty cat heirloom.
Where was that?
Oh, shoot.
I'm coming for you.
Don't be afraid.
Oh god, he's been buried.
Avalanche.
Where are you?
Make a noise.
Precious heirloom.
If you're there, say meow.
Oh, there you are.
And the very last one.
I...
I found the cat figurine.
Yes, you did.
Let's get you inside.
I just realized there's this area, too.
Was this here before?
Where are we going?
Not the child?
Hmm.
Imagine if there was a timer for that.
It's just like you must find the child before...
Before...
Before time runs out.
I want to be able to dig these or something.
Hmm.
This looks like the perfect place to roll a big snowball.
If only my mittens were a bit sturdier.
Ah.
You found the heirloom.
Yes, you did.
Your mother will be glad to know.
I mean, the heirloom is safe.
Can I go through here?
I'm unable to proceed.
I should probably give up.
No, move in!
Just because we're a little thick doesn't mean we give up.
We must come back.
Move in!
Mama, Mama Moomin apparently did raise a quitter.
The wrong you are was unintentional.
Wait, what was it?
Wait, do I have to do this again?
Oh.
Go back inside, you dummy.
Wait, go back inside!
He likes the...
He likes the suffocation.
Don't make her sing the song again.
My yore, yore, yore, yore.
I want to see the Aurora Boyos.
All three kids.
Oh, my precious child.
I should never have sent you outside.
Now he has hypothermia.
Now he's missing an arm.
Please forgive me.
Oh, but mother, you have three children, but only one
porcelain cat figure.
Oh my god.
Family values.
What has this mother instilled in this poor child's brain
that he thinks that he is less valuable than this.
single porcelain cat figurine.
It seems to have lost an ear, though.
I am sorry.
And I've lost all my limbs due to hypothermia.
My wonderful, lovely, irreplaceable child.
Never mind about the cat.
I'm so glad you are safe.
I'll never let my belongings get in the way of that again,
probably.
Filly Junk is more like the Filly Junkler.
What is this?
The Philly jongler.
The clown, the clown, the clown of it all.
The Aurora Borealis at this time of year, at this specific
location, localized within the confines of your kitchen?
Yes.
A mother's love.
I'm so glad someone gets to experience it during this
dreadful winter.
I really am.
Moomin, I don't think you want to be jealous of this.
This is an unhealthy family dynamic, Moomin.
Moomin don't.
Moomin.
May I see it?
No.
Moomin, troll.
I may have been too harsh on you.
Thank you.
If there's anything I can ever do for you.
Just let me know.
Do you have an axe?
I was kind of hoping to invite you to the annual Great
Winter Bonfire.
I will become the Philly Junkler.
Ma'am, how many figurines do you currently own?
Do you play any instruments, by the way?
Oh, a party?
Outside?
You may have saved our lives, but a party is a bit too much
to ask.
Well, Mom, there are three of us and only one min-fat
puppet.
That's too bad.
Let me know if you change your mind.
Change my mind?
Do I strike you as a swayable creature?
She sucks.
Someone's crying.
It says sob, sob, sob.
Such invasive crying.
Rather inconsiderate.
How does she get worse?
How do you get worse?
Someone is crying outside.
I better investigate.
I'm going to investigate.
I would cry as well if it might as wait as well if you my
dear child never came back from the scary outside.
That was so brave what you did dear child.
I'm putting away all my stuff.
I'm keeping this one-eared porcelain cat as a reminder
though.
Beautiful in its own way even though it's not perfect.
I'm taking taking her out with the shovel.
I love my children so much.
Someone called child protective services on this lady right
now.
I thought he said the ancestor for a second.
I wonder who is crying outside.
Do you know?
He's like, I'm an ancestor, not a prophet.
Very brave to rescue the definitely not Hatsune Miku
figurine too.
You must decide, your child or your minke.
Hmm.
Are you upset?
Is it because of the lady of the cold?
Hmm.
You must be freezing.
Why don't you come inside?
Hmm.
I don't deserve it.
I lost my briefcase.
Is this the series The Hippo with the Switchblade meme is
from?
Oh, wait, I think so, right?
It was a gift and now it's gone.
Oh, silly me, I don't deserve gifts.
I can look for it.
That's kind, too kind.
It should be somewhere in this area.
My briefcase.
Is it right under here?
That'd be so funny.
Okay, no.
This is why I can't have it.
nice things.
Oh my god.
Missabel, shut up.
It's lost in the snow like my hopes and dreams.
My briefcase.
So I found it.
I'll let her cry a little bit more though.
What is this?
Fire Wars.
Missabel's briefcase should be around here.
I'm looking for I'm looking for it.
This game is so stinking funny.
It's so goofy.
My briefcase.
Nothing of value here unless you count the sentimental kind.
Alright, quit your whining.
Maybe the jungler was right.
Found your briefcase!
Would you like to come inside now?
I guess.
Thank you.
Wait, why are we inviting you in?
What if she has her own home?
Go inside the movement house.
That we...
We're building the fellowship.
What happened?
Why is it so dark?
You tell me.
This sobbing creature just walked in all unkempt.
Turning off all the lights like some dramatic diva.
Like she owns this place.
My children are afraid of the dark.
Most likely.
Do something momentary.
I just did this.
Come on.
The life in the shadows serves me Is she stuck in there?
And does she lock herself in the bathroom?
Yeah, she's a miserable...
The miserable...
To...
Darkness envelops me!
I can't remember...
Wait, is she...
In here?
No.
I can't remember how many...
I...
around.
Oh wait, no, that goes upstairs.
Do I have to light the entire house?
They shouldn't be coming up here.
This is my personal space.
I guess they really do want the attic and the basement.
Unless?
Yeah.
I like that.
I think it's very funny that we're just turning on the
entire home.
Like all we're lighting all the lights oh wait we'll go to
the attic first since i'm here who cares about anybody
sleeping all right and we're inviting everybody in the world
to stay in our home where did they stay when it wasn't i'm
such a bore just say it i know you're all thinking it oh
what's this Mr. Misabel, by now you've probably realized I'm
gone.
I tried, but I can't live like this anymore.
Though small in stature, you cast such a long, sad shadow
that I feel myself shrinking into dust and rags.
Whenever I'm near you, I've met someone wonderful.
Someone who tells me I have the sparkle of a star and has
promised to make me one.
I'm leaving for somewhere warm to work as an actress.
I look forward to telling you wonderful stories from my new
life.
Don't wait for me.
Your big sister, Mabel.
Dear sister, you are so depressed and it makes...
Get up.
I feel myself shrinking into dust and rags whenever I'm near
you.
Poor Missabel.
I didn't know things were so different.
with her sister oh my god what's this one oh wait to
missabel life is wonderful when you follow your dreams I
live in a wonderful place where the Sun shines all day all
year I've even got someone to clean for me never again will
I wipe a dirty floor my big show is just around the corner a
play by my benefactor who is a renowned playwright I've
already given away all my premiere tickets but I hope you'll
come see it later in the run yes i hope you find your own
dreams to chase i just couldn't wait for it to happen i
needed to follow my own light we all do from mabel huh this
letter has tears on it how horrible
i'm so sad
she's crying about her sister
She didn't even send her a ticket.
Oh, good.
The fire is still blazing away.
Why can't I be more like Philly Jog, such a perfect being,
such a perfect life?
That should be all the lights.
Now to find Mizzabelle.
Wait, there are...
Sounds like the crying is coming from the drawing room.
Oh, okay.
I thought the lights went out again for a second.
Wait.
Okay, good.
I was afraid we were stuck in an endless loop for a second.
The drawing room?
Oh.
She wasn't there.
I knew it.
I hope nobody finds me here.
Opens the door.
Looking around.
It's bad if you're idolizing, Philly Jog.
For real.
I will stay hidden here.
you forever.
I hope nobody finds me here.
Sobs really loudly.
Woe is me.
Okay, she stopped.
Miss Belle, get out of the closet.
There you are.
Why are you hiding in the closet?
I think it's best for everyone if I just retire here.
This way, I won't bother anyone.
Sob, sob.
I love you, and I miss you.
I love that.
That voice around.
Are you sure?
There's plenty of room in the house.
Oh, I wouldn't want to ruin everyone's day like I always do.
Eeyore is more tolerable than this lady is.
Happy Bride to Miss Abel in the closet.
Miss Abel, we're taking you out of the closet.
Would you feel better if I invited you to a party?
A great winter bonfire.
I would love to have you as a guest, and it would really
help me out.
Me at a party, surely I would have ruined it.
This sobbing is giving me a headache.
I didn't mean to disturb you.
I'll sob more quietly.
Sob, sob.
Well, it seems like I have to clean up this mess as always.
You obviously feel bad about yourself.
Whenever I feel down, what do you do, Philly Junk?
I just look at myself in my golden mirror.
Go get a golden mirror movement rope.
What do you read?
We don't have one.
Figures.
No, actually you only have one figure left.
We do have a silver tray in the kitchen.
That will do.
Go get it, will you?
Oh, wrong way.
Look at our race is coming out real nicely.
I got called and missed a bit.
Why is this lady in the closet?
Because she's really sad.
What's going on here?
The silver tray is gone, of course, just as we needed it.
And the window open.
Everybody's just invading my home.
This is an actual horror story.
It's a home invasion.
It's a home invasion story.
Another case for involuntary detective Mumen troll Oh my
gosh
No peace for Mumen Let my guys sleep
Mumen Valley is genuinely full of monstrous creatures of
weirds It really is The characters and movement are so
bizarre and funny.
I like them.
Wow, this is a long loading screen.
The steps are leading in this direction.
I'm destroying these graves.
Look at me.
I'm getting the hang of this detective stuff.
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I meant.
Destroy it all.
This is the weirdest version of the Strangers that I've ever
seen.
It's true!
Whatever use would anyone have of Moomin Mama's silver tray?
If you die in Moomin Valley, you don't become a skeleton,
you become a piece of wood.
Apparently.
I don't make the rules.
Snuffkin was my Ryan Gosling, a distant roamer filled with
knowledge and wisdom, beyond his ears.
Happy to see Minto playing a movement game.
Snuffiken is so cool, no?
I don't think we...
Yeah, I don't think we can go that way yet.
You're right.
Gosling.
That's...
That's a crazy confession.
And I respect it so much.
I, too, have crush on Snuffiken.
Oh, yeah.
We're using all of our abilities.
Nice.
La la la.
More shoveling.
What about Ryan?
Ryan Gosling?
I don't know.
I feel like I don't really have celebrity crushes.
You guys?
Man, just kind of like...
I feel like the closest I can think of is like...
George Clooney or something.
I don't know, though.
Anne Hathaway is cute.
Really?
I think she's pretty cute, yeah.
But I wouldn't be like...
I have a crush on her or anything.
Harrison Ford.
Maybe Harrison Ford.
Wee, wee help, weewee.
Friend, wee wee trapped?
Uh-oh.
Hmm.
Do idols count as celebrities?
I don't count them.
Weewee tree fall.
Oh, troll.
Weewee help.
Oh, no.
Want me to remove the tree and help your friend?
Weewee fast.
No, weewee slow.
Find a lot.
Oh, where am I?
What are we doing over here?
She looks so like...
I have a crush on this one girl who just hit 4444K.
That's crazy.
I also just hit 4444K.
The Phantom is my celebrity crush.
I'm not even a celebrity.
I'm a ghost.
You're my only celebrity crush.
I'm not a celebrity.
Pfft.
I...
I'm simply ghost!
Uh-oh.
Wait, how do I get through here?
Hmm?
Did I say little Mai over there just now?
How do I get through here?
Do I light them on fire?
There's no way I can get through these shrubs.
Hmm.
Maybe there's another way around.
Oh, I see it!
I see it here.
Sometimes it really just looks like a wall.
You're a celebrity that I is?
There's no way I could ever think of myself as a celebrity.
Invited to Ace Combat Release.
I'm not a celebrity.
That's so different.
That ledge up there seems to be my best bet.
Well, Miss 4444K thinks she's not a celebrity.
That's a tiny amount, especially if someone wants to
consider themselves a celebrity.
But movement takes like a crazy tumble.
Easy does it?
Just don't look down as he's looking down.
This game is going to turn me into the jokester.
What does this have for you?
Nice.
We're still running.
We're going far, far away.
I have a crush on this super cute green streamer who will be
performing in New York soon.
She's just so cute, especially her tapier ears.
I agree.
I also have a crush on girls with tapier ears.
But,
but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, oh,
we have to avoid it.
How far do we have to follow these tracks?
I'm getting far from home.
Oh.
There's something in the...
What the heck?
There may be higher quantities, but the quality of those
444K can't be beat.
So true.
Oh my god.
You can fill three to five football stadiums with your fans.
Celebrity.
No, I can't.
Actually, I don't know how big a football field is.
Shut up!
Oh, it's got a piece of the vase!
Hold on, too.
Wait, we gotta slide down here really quick.
I'm getting there.
So many, so many wood.
Oh, wow!
That also gave us wood.
Moomin don't play.
Moomin said, today you don't give us wood.
a home.
The streamer of 4444K subs is in divine.
Buy hoops.
That bird is clutching something.
Hey, that's a piece of moment mama's race!
Give it back.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, that's where we came from.
No, just kidding.
This is where we go easy does it croaky making noise again
been telling her doggy first no wait can i go up this way
wait i want to go this way because there's a little
gravesite and a little friend don't worry winter being i'm
here yeah oh my gosh we almost have only a hundred left
found you now it's dangerous to be out alone you should we
troll play we we oh that was a guy playing hide-and-seek
wait oh here we go again that's our guy playing
hide-and-seek that's right i thought that was the guy that
was trapped
wait if i do this nice i thought so i thought it would be
like that what about this Nice!
Oops.
More wood?
Yes, yes.
What
is that up there?
More wood?
Guys, we're so close to just having 100 left.
Look at her.
Little Mai!
Wait, have you seen the silver tree somewhere?
How did she jump?
Oh my god.
She's insane.
Uh, let's go this way first.
What's down here?
More wood.
Oh, oops.
Nice thinking.
24.
This area is huge.
Getting back is gonna be a huge pain.
Oh my god, now we're cl- we're- We're climbing.
This must be leading to the mountaintop.
We're going to the top of the mountain?
Wait, guys, can I show you something real quick?
We're running.
There, it feels so fresh up here.
You're welcome.
Stingy.
There's 100 blocks of our woods left.
Little my.
Please don't go.
This is not a game.
Hmm.
Seems like I can't get across from here.
Maybe I can find a way to get that rope over here.
It's not a game.
I think actually this might be a life or death situation.
I think she might.
might make this a life or death situation if you know what i
mean in my home why is she always so mad i know she's got
attitude she's got spunk and we we love it
are we sure my tiny wow my teeny tiny Gloves can take care
of that.
Comfy Minky for comfy night?
You're liking the game?
I'm loving the game.
It's so fun.
What's going on in there?
Whose eyeballs are staring at me?
This area is huge, though.
It is a big, big area.
We reached the mountaintop, and now we're going down?
We're going down, down.
Oh, dang it, I keep doing that.
So sensitive.
There we go.
Less than 100.
Sugar, we're going down swinging.
I'm burning.
I'm getting bullied.
There better be something really good at the end of this.
I better get both the axe and something.
else.
I don't know.
The axe and the thing that makes me allow to mine and
everything.
I better get 50 woods.
Two axes.
Yeah.
Double axe action.
Double axe.
If you know what I'm talking about.
You know what I'm saying.
You know what I'm...
What is this?
Oh.
You know what I'm putting down.
And my axe.
Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Moving too comfy.
Woo!
Wait, can I go through that?
Okay, nice.
We're still going down some more.
And more?
Okay.
Where are we?
Where is she?
Wait, where are we?
How did we get so far from our goal?
Like, actually.
How did we get any closer to getting to that side of the
mountain?
Goal.
weather's making me eepie too?
Yeah.
A babe.
In Australia.
Go go.
Oh.
Wait a second.
We might actually be onto something.
We might actually have done it.
Somehow.
Finally!
I can climb up the rope.
This was the longest tangent.
I wonder how far Lil' Amai has gotten.
Pushed it.
I don't have anything to chop this tree with.
Okay, we will.
We're getting the axe, boys.
It's time for the axe.
That's the only way we can get home.
Oops.
It's axe in time.
I must axe you, of course.
In here I'm hungry.
I might go get my kisser to you Case a dealer Alligator case
a dealer step aside stroller
I've always wanted to sled hmm little my with my silver tray
I should have known
What is her problem?
She's...
She's the stinker of all time.
Everybody knows this.
She is the stinker of all time!
He's gonna go beat her up.
With his moom and fists.
A little
thief?
No.
I mean, maybe a little.
Run!
Ha!
You should have seen his face.
Did you see that?
I'm breaking all kinds of records here.
Then they were set by me in the first place, which makes it
twice as impressive.
Is that why you like her, stinkers, United look at the way
she's looking at me you've never gone sledding you need to
fix that at some point hmm well my that's some that is a
moment mama silver tray and besides
oh look at her go my number one student admittedly I only
have one How can I catch up with her?
For you, that would take years of training.
Dang!
Or you could find an alternative path or shortcut perhaps.
Catch up with a little my...
Little my...
I could follow her down.
Or...
We shovel our way through here.
Wait, what if I do follow her down?
Wait, there's a friend here!
Wee, wee, bird, wee, wee, bad, wee, wee, self-bad.
Both the best and the worst.
Yeah, we got completely roasted.
He has no confidence in our abilities.
What is wrong, friend?
Wait, you're telling me I'm gonna have to come all the way
back up here.
Help this guy out.
Hi there.
Are you upset about something?
and why haven't you made it to the bonfire we we bird bad we
we bird we we took we book we book we bad we we hmm a bad
bird took your bad book
trying to find the what the requirements are to be a
celebrity in Minto's eyes do eight concert appearances a
one-year cow?
I have to be in a movie.
What kind of book were you reading, huh, little guy?
We book we secret.
Self-secret.
Secret bad.
We self-bad.
We read.
Oh.
It's sort of a diary with your secrets and a bird took it.
I would be upset too if someone took my diary.
Maybe I can help get it back.
We know read.
I promise I won't read it.
I have promised this before.
I have made this promise before that I would not read
somebody's secret letter.
We will decide how much of a, how annoying it is to get the
diary.
Poor fella.
Is this a shortcut, you think?
Well, uh, oh, oh, oh, there she is.
Hmm.
Little Mai!
I have to find a way down.
I love how Minto doesn't think she's popular, so moi.
What do you mean?
I think...
I think it's, you know, I don't even know what to think.
I don't know, I don't know what to think.
I don't know what to think.
Wait, we have two ways we can go.
We can either slide down this way or we can go the other
way.
Um, wait, what if we go down that way?
Well, what's over here, you know?
Let's try this first, because it's less final.
Less finite.
Oh, it's just a thing.
Which is gonna be...
Wood.
Okay, good.
Stop pressuring me, though, to be a celebrity.
Look, I'm only a celebrity if they talk about me on a
Hollywood bus.
And they would never.
So, sorry, guys.
You know, those bus tours where they're like...
And this is...
This is Anne Hathaway's house.
They would never...
They would never say this is Mint Phantom's house.
Oh, wait, where are we?
Where are we, actually?
It looks like she came down this way, maybe?
Oh, there she is.
Hello.
You have...
We have Hollywood ghost tours.
too.
Great progress, little my.
Why do I say it with like a, I don't know, sometimes I have
an accent, I don't realize what it is.
It seems you have taken my lessons to heart.
Wait, but it sounds like Australia, no?
Little my.
Did you embrace my lecture about believing in yourself?
never doubted myself for a second exemplary that's why it
makes me a great skier and everyone else I teach as well a
little boy excuse me excuse now to truly become a champion
ahem excuse me he's like Laughing in my face.
I would really like Moomin Mama's silver trait back.
I think they're supposed to be finished.
I don't think, I know.
All progress starts with a clear definition of your goal.
Speaking of goals, I'm ready to advance from sledding to
skiing.
Of course.
Well, you seem to find yourself without skis.
Mine are too big and besides.
I was born with them.
I would really...
like the silver tray bag.
He's raging out.
Well, I would really like something.
skis so looks like we have some common interests there
namely getting me my skis so you can get your silver tray
back yes if you could find some sticks I could craft a
perfect pair of skis some sticks I gotta get two sticks what
a tremendous winter we're having all feels right in the
world wait can we go down this yeah hmm I shouldn't leave
before getting the silver tray oh this leaves okay that's a
tree not a stick it's a big house how how thick of sticks
are we talking about like are we talking twigs oh single
stick huh a stick
Alright, one more stick.
It's right over here.
It's right in here.
Actually, it is in here.
Oh, what's in there?
Wait, is there a stick in here or not?
Oh, I forgot!
It's up, my boy.
Oh.
How far do we have to go for this stick?
Oh wait Is the phrase It's a stick up your butt Or is a
stick in the mud
More sticks I think I have Oh it's both Okay I thought I
messed it up
Shortcut Awesome
Hmm do?
There you are.
I never expected to see you again.
What do you think I died?
What?
Are these sticks for my skis?
Hand them over.
There you are.
Wait, give me the silver tray first.
What?
Do you think I would keep the tray?
Because you're right because I was actually going to.
We know.
However, I appreciate your skills in negotiation.
Here you are.
Look at my two apprentices.
You've come so far.
Still a long way to go, though.
Wait, I'm also an apprentice too.
And let me get cracking on these skis.
Wait, does that mean we can go faster if we get skis too?
That would be sick.
Meh.
They're a perfect pair, if I may say so myself.
You may.
Now all this sporty stuff has made me hungry.
There's food at the Moomin House.
I'll race you to it.
You don't live there.
The Moomin House?
Wait.
I haven't asked Moomin, Mom, or Moomin?
and Papa for permission to raid the pantry.
Nor can I.
At least I got my silver tray back.
The silver lining with this tray is that it also works as a
mirror.
We gotta go back to Misabel.
Oh, geez.
Mountain King.
Yes?
I fixed this rope so you sightseers can get to the
mountaintop risk-free.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Better hurry to the Moomin house before Little Mai eats all
my food.
It's not even her food.
It's none of your foods.
Where are the Moomin cops?
He's also hibernating.
This feels illegal.
This has to be illegal.
They're gonna wake up from hibernation so starved.
god we saved all that food for when we wake up because you
know we're so hungry
it's all oh i feel bad for when women parents wake up me too
finland is lawless what all the mess is gone somebody
cleaned while i was away oh wow somebody did something kind
that's crazy Mizabelle, you got out!
That's great!
The place is so clean, I thought for a moment, Moomin Mama
had woken up.
I told Mizabelle she'd feel better if she cleaned up.
I'm not sure she does, but at least the place looks
wonderful!
I brought Moomin Mama silver try.
I just realized that Mizabelle is a maid.
Do you think this is me?
Hold on, I'm gonna eat some A snack Am I miserable
Mintable Let me look This is So much worse than I thought
Well, of course, you're all messy after cleaning all day.
I mean, who does your hair?
Your makeup?
Where's your jewelry?
I didn't know I needed that to be happy.
Of course you didn't.
And that's why you're miserable.
Oh my god.
A perfect interior starts with a perfect exterior.
Yes, I think I can work with this.
need some makeup jewelry and a new dress.
Wait, I didn't get the axe.
I just realized.
Let me guess.
You want me to get it for you?
Well, we all want Miss Abel to feel better, right?
Now that she's done cleaning.
Make up jewelry and a dress.
Woman mama should have all those things around the house.
We're taking her clothes now, too?
Wait.
we can go in the bathroom now
the key to Moomin mama's jewelry box which means she locked
everything away because she does not want people taking
stuff I think that means we shouldn't go in there oh my gosh
hello uh-huh But guess you have, Mumen Troll.
Imagine not feeling confident.
Inconceivable!
Sorry, I mean, don't have to go.
Thank you so much for this come-faced rave.
You're such...
You're so great and lovely.
And remember, when you feel down or in trouble, we're always
on your side to do even the impossible.
Mobius one, thank you.
Thank you, good night!
Thank you so much!
They're just...
Honk-shoeing over.
Oh, this must be the jewelry box.
This is what I was trying to get into earlier.
We got a pearl necklace.
Mum and Mama smiles when putting on her necklace.
I hope Mishabelle will feel the same way.
I understand the sentiment.
But this is your mob stuff.
Wait, so we wanted it.
What was it?
Makeup and a dress.
I thought the makeup would be in the...
In the bathroom for sure.
Reducting everyone, Moomin has expanded his criminal empire
to include stealing all of his mob stuff.
This game is so funny.
It's so cozy and goofy.
Just like Moomin.
I love the OST is too good.
Wait, there's a dress over here.
A lovely frock cut to flatter most figures.
Moomin, Mama, loves this dress.
I hope it will bring Mizzabelle some joy.
This letter has been crumpled.
It's still possible to read it.
Uh-oh.
To my sister.
Letting go of the past has been the hardest.
Yet most rewarding thing I've ever done.
Last night's premiere was everything I dreamt of and more.
As I basked in the applause and admiration of the crowd, my
beloved, the celebrated playwright, proposed right there on
the red carpet.
I am to be married and I suspect our family will soon grow
imagine that you an aunt I am considering adopting a title
befitting my new station in life lady Macbell the artist
formerly known as Mabel yes what do you think I don't think
she was I don't think she I don't think she likes that idea
very much where would the makeup be in the basement I
don't think she likes that idea very much, considering it
was all crumpled up.
I'll double check in here again one more time, but...
Poor Misabelle.
Oh, here it is.
I knew it.
I had a feeling.
Woman mommy uses makeup for special occasions.
I want Misabelle to feel special.
Okay, I'm glad I checked again.
The basement makeup.
You guys, have you ever put on makeup in a basement
there you are she was about to turn off all the lights again
I don't want you to see me like this
I'm not a serial killer so no well we won't have too much
longer I'm gonna kill you now give the poor thing some space
movement role just go into the bathroom and apply like I
told you, Misabelle.
Hurry now, and we'll all be better off.
You're not gonna at least do the makeup for her?
What if she doesn't know how to do it?
I wonder how long a makeover takes.
What about her hair?
With Misabelle, it could take hours.
Months?
I am ready.
Let's inspect.
Nisabelle, you look...
Mumen, don't be like this.
Mumen, say something nice.
Wait, she does look so cute.
Like a pig with lipstick.
No!
She looks so cute!
What?
Tons and tons of wonderful lipstick.
I feel awful.
No, I think you are wonderful.
You're just saying that to be nice.
She even did her hair.
What's wrong with saying something to be nice?
I give up.
She clearly prefers being miserable.
This is impossible.
Did somebody say the...
How do you pronounce Himmelin?
No?
Definitely not.
You're approaching the whole project all wrong.
All she needs is confidence.
That starts with a positive outlook.
Good luck with that.
No one has ever pronounced it.
It is impossible.
I believe you.
Thanks.
I don't need it, though.
Now let's turn that frown upside down.
I already tried with lipstick.
I'm not sure about this.
All I wanted to do was invite her to the bonfire.
If I say yes, will you leave me alone?
Yes, say yes.
That's the right outlook.
Yes, I will join you at the bonfire.
makes you happy.
Hooray!
A breakthrough!
Through the power of positivity.
Hmm.
I think the age is silent.
Is it?
Can I remove my makeup now?
Never ask permission, but yes, I'll allow it.
She used it all up.
Mama Moomin has nothing now.
this doesn't feel as good as I thought it would of course
you don't feel good look at the state of your equipment
mm-hmm you look totally unprepared for winter no offense but
also some offense my equipment what's wrong with it your
value in the wild is directly correlated to the value of
your equipment ask any scare.
Some offense.
No offense.
But some offense.
Look at your mittens, for starters.
They're all worn out.
I'm surprised you'd get anywhere.
Uh-oh.
Take the incredibly sturdy ball of yarn.
I use it for all my clothing.
Oh, good.
Yay!
Now we get to go to, uh, back to, uh, we gotta go get
upgraded.
I would help you fix your mittens, but I'm all tied up.
You will have to ask someone else.
This is exactly the kind of thing Mum and Mama will do for
me.
I know.
I'll ask Tuteki.
She's incredibly handy.
I'll finish up my positivity bootcamp here.
My biggest challenge yet.
I'm pooped!
Oh my gosh, and you're also finished!
Let's go get some...
Aw.
Now let's train the art of positivity.
Say something positive about me.
You're very loud.
Thanks.
I've been working on that.
And so can you.
Louder is always better.
This is giving me a headache.
We're not making her miserable sad.
making her miserable annoyed louder now you should move your
arms more when you speak like me
in general just try to say what i do and copy it no thanks
yes please would be the appropriate response try again yeah
let's go get her are mittens that are definitely not made
for kittens
all right hmm him you and some of my mittens are not good
enough huh I wonder what he meant I should ask to take help
this way
the crossword what was it what was it wait oh gosh that
reminded me of something I can't remember what it was like
her whole interaction.
Dang it, I completely lost my brain.
My brain is not braining so much today.
I think with the bigger mittens, we were able to go into the
cave and do something, I think.
We know brain tonight.
Oh!
Did you guys see that?
Well, that was weird, yeah.
That was quite weird.
Tootiki, apparently my muttons are all tattered.
Could you fix them for me?
I wonder what the flickering was.
That's it?
Hold on, let me hear what my...
I thought maybe my switch was, like, overheating, but it
doesn't seem like...
You got this incredibly sturdy barred...
Bar-bar-b-b-b-b-b-b-bard.
Bar-b.
So then the happy brain juice.
Yeah!
Yonk!
Yes, I guess you have worn them out.
Stay here and I'll fix them for you.
I am.
Painfully loving Minto Bulwars.
Here you go.
I've reinforced your mittens.
You should be able to handle the snow better now.
That reminds me.
I saw a little nigh down by the pond.
Did you invite her to go to the Great Winter Bonfire?
I tried.
Then I suggest you try harder.
Little Mai can be elusive.
But do you really think she'd miss the party of the year?
When you put it like that, to the pond then.
Kiko, thank you so much for the fun.
Good dude.
Thank you, thank you.
If you want to practice with your new mittens, try rolling a
big...
That's what it was, the big snowball.
And we should be able to push it.
Oh!
Wait!
Stardier mittens.
Does that mean...
Oh, you have to hold it.
I think then we can make this.
Oh, that's kind of tough though.
It's kind of tough to push.
Like, I can't push it at a diagonal.
Oh, nice.
La la la...
Oh.
Huh.
That wasn't so hard.
Now off to find little my by the pond.
Wait, but what if there's more?
Oh, I can.
I just have to be, like, kind of careful with it, I guess.
By the pond, you say.
where was that oh there was other things that i could make
giant snowball with but i don't remember what oh wait this
is not the pond i i remember where the pond is it's back
towards my home this is like the sea yeah in the mountain
yeah yeah yeah yeah
the thing in the i wonder if because we have better uh
matches if we can melt the stuff in here Let's check it out.
Let's see if we can give it a shot.
Let's give it a shot.
The sea is just a really big pond.
Exactly.
Well, they do say across the pond.
So...
Doesn't seem the case.
It doesn't seem like it works.
They say that, they say that every day, all the time.
If the sea is, what if the sea is just a really, really,
well actually if it's a big pond, wouldn't it then be a
lake?
Alan Wake.
Alan Wake at the lake, John Wake.
Picky, picky.
Picky, pick, pick, pick, pick, pick, pick, pick, pick.
Wait, at the lake.
This way.
It's not a lake.
It's an ocean.
Wait, if that's an ocean, then what?
Alan Ocean.
Ocean's 11?
Little boy should be this way.
Hurry up.
potter.
Where?
Oceans 11.
Oh, wait a second.
I think I see it.
Yes, I see where I need to do it.
I think this was the other area that we figured we can make
a ball.
Okay.
It's like a little slower if you don't go, you know.
No, no moment.
The other way.
Yeah, there we go.
Okay, we can climb up there, or...
Not yet.
There we are.
Hmm.
A rope.
Somebody must have climbed up here.
I don't mind.
There was something south, too?
Yeah, but we can't go there yet.
We do not have the ability, unfortunately.
I'm glad we're so strong that this takes only one hit It's
kind of insane too
Are you guys feeling relaxed?
Is this relaxing you?
Somebody has been camping recently Fire is still warm They
must be near If it was a little high It would probably be
messier though Okay
It is pretty comfy, right?
Whoever left this probably wouldn't mind me taking it.
We're almost halfway to 100 wood now, you guys.
We're making great progress.
I'm glad you guys are cozy.
Oh, no.
Amazing scenery.
And somebody has put up a tent?
That hat.
Masaka.
Is it?
Could it be?
Hmm.
Who could it be?
Ryan Gosling.
Could it really be?
Masaka.
Oh my gosh.
Even snow.
I almost had snuck in.
Even Moomin is like, maybe.
I wonder whose tent that was.
I don't think Little Maya is into camping.
A friend.
How do I get to you?
You were trapped.
Goodbye.
Shadow the Hedgehog.
I love the way Moomin...
like just tumbles down the ice.
Doesn't even attempt to slide.
Just full-on tumble.
Imagine playing this game if you had no idea who these
characters were.
I would...
I don't even know what I would think.
Maybe I would be like...
I don't know.
I would be like, why is everybody...
He's so eccentric.
That's me watching this stream.
Then you're probably wondering, why is everybody so
eccentric and strange?
Music!
That tune feels familiar.
That's you.
Well, this is a...
You can always start a movement anytime.
Milman welcomes all all times of the year
That really looks like Snuffkin
Who are you?
Oh, you are not him I'm Muffkin Jockster Jockster
I am known by many names.
The imposter.
Have you seen Little My?
You may simply call me the Jockster.
Ignores your question.
You see, it's important that I find her.
I have many things.
Wonder.
I am my own master.
Dependent on no one.
You are no snuffkin.
But most of all, I am hungry.
Would you care to join me for supper?
Huh.
Oh, actually.
Very much.
I'm starving.
Good.
We'll be needing some food.
I saw some nuts in the tree.
That's for dinner.
Girl dinner.
Girl did handful of nuts for dinner.
did you want me to get them for you it is considered common
courtesy for guests to contribute hmm sorry I didn't mean to
be rude I will find some nuts you are forgiven this time now
we'll be needing some bark as well for the fire tis I
knuffsten I don't know how I got these clothes I'm the
jockster baby the jokester And this whole camp is a snowy
mess.
Wait, is it jockster or jokester?
We'll call him the jokester.
But we really don't want to meet the strokester.
Remove some snow while you're at it, and I'll do the rest.
You're asking me to do a whole lot already.
Okay, so we're collecting birch.
Says ew.
I'm telling you guys, you don't want to meet him.
Okay.
You don't wanna know.
It's bad news, bears.
There.
All the snow is gone from the camp.
Grab it,
grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it, grab
it.
Oh, that's just wood.
What does a bark look like?
Oh, this is a bark?
Grab the bark, grab the bark.
It's a bark, a birch bark.
Grab it, grab it.
Oh, how am I supposed to get these down the night?
He brings a lot of positive energy to the sish, which is
happening.
Wood.
Noise.
You can't get in here either.
Oh, snowballs.
Maybe.
Oh, yeah, let's try it.
Oh, you're so right.
You're so right!
A hazelnut.
Finally, I get my hands on these nuts!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, there we go.
You can't, you can't tell me nothing with how Lumen says
too.
Oh, another birch.
And...
Another...
Another birch!
Very nice, very nice.
Uh...
Let's see.
Let's grab some... We need what, one more birch?
Oh, it's probably in here.
Oh my gosh, sometimes it's so hard to tell.
The game is so pretty.
But sometimes it's so hard to tell.
I need some gamer paint for real.
Where's my Gamerbane?
There it is.
Alright.
Let's grab these.
Some yellow snow.
No!
That's disgusting.
Why would you think that?
And then the last two were over here, right?
Last.
Wait.
How many more did we need?
I don't remember how many we were at it.
Why are you guys sitting scattered?
I just woke up.
Why did you upload for your two squirrels making it up to
the works?
I accidentally put it there instead of my own personal.
I'm so sorry.
We'll have it again.
Go back to the joke star.
Those are business squirrels.
They've been business.
This is sufficient.
Now we'll be needing a cooking pot.
Luckily there's one in a tree nearby.
Why is it there?
A tree?
Are you sure?
Yes, I was homebrewing last night and things got a little
out of hand.
Can we see these squirrels?
Only because you asked.
I'll show you where to find it.
Not everyone can be as self-reliant as me.
But if it's in the tree, I guess we can, like, oh, here it
is.
Hello?
It should be over here somewhere.
Oh, but these bushes are blocking the way.
I can't get past.
Oh, everything is so difficult in winter.
Sorry for disappointing you.
Alas, you did not disappoint me only yourself tremendously.
In order to traverse the Lady of the Cold's domain, you need
to unburden yourself and move like the wind.
But how?
Can you show me?
It's easier if I tell you.
So, bend down like a branch under the snow.
And release!
Does anything happen if you throw...
Yeah, let's throw a snowball at the jokester.
I'm not playing.
Oh!
Look at me!
I'm flying exactly like the wind!
Uh, yes.
You look just like the wind.
Don't be a hater, jokester.
He just left.
Is it only in the eyes?
I think we can only dash in the eyes.
There's something in that tree.
Nice shot.
Whoops.
Oh, it's not just in the tree.
It's anywhere.
Jackpot.
Or at least a pot.
What's over here?
A whole lot of nothing.
Alright.
These are speed run tactics now.
Wait, what's over here?
It's this way.
Is this where level my went?
Well, maybe we should go give the pot back first.
Just like the wind.
We are so graceful.
The intended way to play this game.
Nice.
This is your cooking pot?
This will have to do.
What do you mean?
Is this not it?
I'm so confused right now.
Me too.
I'm so confused.
What a jokester.
Give into the great mysteries of life.
Everything's more interesting than...
Now let's get cooking.
Since you've helped prepare the meal, I shall reward you
with a song.
Wait, he can sing at the bonfire!
It was taught to me by somebody close to me.
It consists of one part expectation, two part spring
melancholy.
And the rest is just the boundless joy of being alone.
Alone?
Why would anyone enjoy that?
He misses spring.
Oh.
Did the guy leave him there?
Wait, Moomin fell asleep and...
Oh!
He left...
Jokester, perhaps you could play at the Great Winter Bond?
Jokester, he left Moomin to die in the cold!
He just left!
I could really have needed him.
At least he gave me food and let me warm myself by his fire.
Hmm?
Wait a minute.
I provided the fire, the pot, and the food.
Maybe I don't need him.
Or anyone.
Moment, check your kidneys.
Oh, except I obviously do.
But maybe I'm not so hopeless after all.
Oh.
Wrong again, loser.
Little my.
Why would you call me that?
The height of responsibility.
Because you're losing the game.
I didn't know we were playing one.
I love angry movement.
That's the first step.
I've been losing.
Will you join me in building the Great Winter Bonfire?
Only if you beat me in a snowball fight, which you won't.
Again?
Part two?
Oh, we gotta catch her.
I'm gonna body slam her with my big Moomin troll body.
Um, stare, no dance.
He just lost the game!
Are you trapped on the ice?
I can rescue you.
Wee wee no rescue wee wee wee stare wee wee no wee dances
wee hmm oh I'm sorry you want to dance alone oh your angry
movement voice sounds like your snake impression no they're
too completely different big fire wee wee dance bad wee wee
practice wee wee I'm sure you're a great dancer but I won't
stare mm-hmm wee We snow- Oh, sorry, I didn't press
anything, but it went through.
Snowmen staring at you?
They're made of snow, I'm sure they won't do you any harm.
Self, we, shy.
Well, I can relate.
Perhaps I could look around, see if I find any snowmen.
I'll deal with them.
Don't you worry.
I'm a professional at taking out these guys.
Wait, can I do it with my body?
No, I have to do it with my fists.
Oh, whoops.
I pressed the wrong button.
Oh, I did it again.
I just, I'm really keen on body slamming, though, I think.
Still, though, I want to go...
We'll do this one real quick, but...
So curious.
About...
Oh.
About what was in that area we just unlocked.
Moving with the knife.
Do you think we got all of them?
Oh no!
Secret.
Oh, it says four out of five.
Okay, I missed that.
At least the jockster left some firewood.
I mean, jokester.
Snowmen are the weeping angels of the world.
Yeah, they're actually evil.
I'm doing everybody a great service.
Oh!
wood are actually in this game you know what i mean because
if it shouldn't be that you have to i don't know you're all
gone now nobody's staring at you oh troll stare oh sorry
i'll give you your privacy we we happy we we would gift oh
firewood for me now that'll always come in handy i hope to
see your dance by the great winter bonfire.
How much did he give us?
I'm actually not sure.
And hay-ya!
Nice!
Yeah!
Because I can't imagine they expect you to go through every
single one of these, you know what I mean?
To get the wood.
But we have...
We've gotten through quite a bit of it now.
Only 66 left.
And we need the music and we need the fire.
I can't believe we got duped by Timu Snuffkin.
I'm so sad about that.
Probably more than 125 total.
We recalled.
We we fire.
We we help.
um yeah i imagine that's jokester puts some respect on his
name um yeah i imagine there's more than 125 because
otherwise it would be so what you have to find it would be
so tough you know
hello there we go there we go now there we go there we go
yeah imagine missing one that's what I mean though I mean
we're getting one right now here right yeah yeah I think
there's actually one up here too I think there's one up here
I saw a little grave marker I feel like we've been here
before, but also so many of these areas look the same.
I think it's funny calling Jockster a bootleg snuffkin
because in the story he's like way older.
Yeah, but they tricked us knowing that we would think it's
snuffkin.
Wait, did my game just... Did that just happen again?
You seem to be freezing.
We were you cold.
Wee-wee.
Hmm.
I could help you make a fire.
I could really use any firewood I find for the great winter
bonfire.
Hmm.
But this poor soul seems to need it even more.
It took out some of mine.
Take this firewood.
You need it more than me.
Oh.
Cold.
Wee-wee-wee.
Wee.
You're shivering.
Let me light it for you.
Whoa.
That was set ablaze.
There.
Hope this helps.
Fire.
Wee, wee, warm heart.
Wee, wee.
Wee, friend.
Wee, wee, warm wee.
Maybe I'll see you around the great winter bonfire.
That will be even warmer.
And hopefully with even more friends.
Aw!
Wee, friend, take wee, wee.
A piece of Mum and Mama's vase?
Now that warms my heart.
Thank you.
Seven out.
Oh, we're still missing a lot of the base, though.
Okay, good.
We did stuff here.
Now we can body slam our way through the bushes.
I'm trying to think of a place where the bushes were
blocking our way.
Where?
Message in the bottle.
Food for the winter being.
Missing pieces.
Otherwise...
No, that was the...
There was some at Philly John's house.
Yes.
Oops.
Yes, there was.
Thank you.
So we'll head over there.
This must be where the jokester made his...
escape.
Wait, what's this?
Where are we?
The lower pond.
Oh, we haven't been down here yet.
That's exciting.
Uh-huh.
Oh, come on.
How did I literally...
Get in between those.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
I got you, you bastard!
Yeah.
That was so clutch.
Oh my goodness.
You stinking bird.
Why do you sound like that?
Oh, I thought I was stuck for a second.
Wait, we can go this way.
Oh, this is where we need...
Oh, hello.
This is where we need the snowball.
So I'll probably have to get rid of some of these.
Oh, oops.
Uh, you?
Nice.
Okay, that should be good.
Hoi!
You can dig up that snow.
Wait, was there snow to dig up?
Wait, I missed it.
Oh gosh, I don't like the snowballs.
They're kind of annoying.
They're kind of really annoying.
Oh, here!
That's right!
Thank you guys.
Again, I always miss it.
I snowball!
Aw man.
Wait, is this a time thing?
Oh geez, okay.
We're running, we're running, we're running, we're running.
Don't get anxious.
Don't get nervous.
Don't get anxious or nervous.
Okay.
It's just so much easier to pull it than to push it.
He's heavy.
Okay.
Run around.
No!
I need the...
I need an axe.
Hmm.
I don't have anything to chop this tree with.
I have my fist?
Just push it over!
It's literally on its last leg.
Moomin.
I believe in your strength.
I believe in your strength!
Yeah, Moomin's definitely strong enough.
Little Mai.
Hey, over here!
I don't
have all day.
Fight me!
Feel the fury!
Feel the feel.
Come on!
Fight me!
I can't.
I have important work to do.
Blah!
Learn to enjoy yourself.
I don't understand why anyone would enjoy getting their face
stuffed with snow!
No!
Pretend you're doing it to me.
Wait.
Wouldn't I be doing it to you?
Thing, where'd she go?
Where'd she go?
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Did I beat her?
I'll let you have this round.
But the next one is mine.
I don't even see how much health she had.
Next one.
Yeah, point blank in her face.
Come on, warm-up doesn't count.
What if I body-slammed you, huh?
What if I body-slammed you?
Well, you ain't done with me yet.
Oh my gosh.
What am I?
I am busy.
The battle must go on.
Okay, come on.
Come on.
Let's go for another round.
I'm ready.
The battle must go on.
Why does she have more health than me?
Oh, shoot.
Oh, she's coming after me!
Yeah, that's what you get.
When did she get five health?
I sniped her for real.
Woo!
She powered up.
Yeah.
Nice shot, Moomin.
This is actually fun.
I'm like, I'm doing this the easiest.
The best strat, though.
Yeah.
You got me.
Let's see how you perform and the pressure is actually on.
Wait, what?
There's more?
Yuhu!
Camillo!
This will be the last one, I promise, she says.
You guys believe her?
She's such a sore loser.
I know it's so funny.
Not finding any of you would.
This will be the last one.
You may have won the two first matches, but I'm going to win
this most important one.
Hmm?
Standing.
Challenge accepted.
Oh my gosh, wait.
She powered up like crazy.
Oh my gosh.
Don't get me!
Ouch!
Wait, where'd my goal?
I lost my snowball.
Yeah!
How is she doing it?
Oh, oops.
I messed up.
Oh dang it, I messed up.
No!
I was so close.
I can't see her anymore.
Where is she?
Oh, got her!
You're still ten years too young to do this to me, you
little my.
Hey, no cheating, she says.
I wasn't cheating.
Got you.
How fun.
Mm-hmm.
Wow.
Hmm.
You're right.
Winter is overrated.
Oh.
I guess I'll keep my part of the bargain, helping you drive
winter out or whatever.
Hmm.
Aim by, aim by.
Bring spring back.
It's like the deadpan stand.
This snowpacking time is exhilarating.
It's...
This dead pilot's stare just...
Just... just staring.
Bring... spring back.
Uh-huh.
By the way, you should probably have back to the Moomin'
house.
There was a strange noise coming from there.
Uh-oh.
Like someone being murdered.
Check it out if you're not too busy goofing around.
Oh no, a murder in my home?
I think I'm too busy to look into that.
Huh.
I can't believe I actually enjoyed that.
Oh well, I should go back to the movement house to look
after my guests.
Do you guys hear every time you get like the complete a
quest thing?
of Streamlabs notification.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
There was one that like it would go like like exactly how it
sounds.
It's so nostalgic for me because before I had like you know
sounds or anything I used that one.
So it's kind of like whoa it sounds like the old Streamlabs.
Anything in here?
I can't believe the way that we get through these bushes is
by, like, body slamming them.
It's pretty funny to me.
Time to bring it back.
Maybe.
I saw someone saying they were cold, though.
Where'd they go?
They were like, oh, it's so cold.
Oh, here.
Help!
Oh my god, they're frozen!
Hmm.
Poor thing, I'm coming!
Just need to figure out how.
Oh my god!
Ring!
Spring buck.
Can I actually get through?
No!
I was worried about that!
Oh no, I have to go around.
Oh, don't...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
It's getting huge.
This might be my biggest snowball yet.
It's ginormous.
Yeah!
It was a massive.
Wait, I don't know how to get this guy out.
Maybe, though.
I'll be with you soon.
Thank warm thoughts.
Maybe to think about your parents or best friend.
Break the ice.
I don't have anything to do that.
I don't have anything to break this ice with.
Okay, I'm just gonna have to leave you there.
And, uh...
So sorry for the trouble.
Bye!
Oh.
Do you guys think the squirrel is still alive?
I want to believe.
I think the squirrel is still alive.
Sorry, I'm looking to make sure I didn't forget or miss
anything.
Because we were just doing that.
Alive and kissing.
Absolutely.
All right, back to Moomin House.
I think he'll be...
I think he'll defrost.
at the bonfire I think it would be really great I mean she
disappeared so it's not that he's gone gone you don't know
what happened to him music coming from inside is this what
she meant by somebody getting murdered because just sound
wait yeah it does sound like a bad music I should probably
go back to hold hold your horses moving we have some other
things to body slam Oh, gone, gone, just gone.
Gotta get some sleep.
Good night, Maddie!
Good night!
I'll probably be wrapping up soon, too.
I'm quite sleepy myself.
Like I do some more packing.
Before I sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep,
sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
So pretty.
Here we go.
It's this, but I can't even, I don't have the axe to even
chop the wood.
Yeah, I don't have anything.
I'm sure once we get the axe and are able to chop wood, like
our collection of wood will double, triple even.
Yeah, I can't.
I can't do anything here.
Oh well.
We tried.
Skyrocket.
Wood stonks to the moon!
Axe should help you finish up all the quests.
I think so too.
Well, Axe and the Ice Pick.
The Axe feels OP though with how many things required at the
moment.
There are so many things we can't do.
Trying to think of any other places that had bushes.
Oh well Let's go see what's going on Wait Oh, never mind
Take a check I got too into it Wait, aren't my parents
asleep?
What are you guys doing in here?
Oh my gosh Amun, Mama, Amun and Papa Are gonna wake up from
all the racket?
Pop Pop Oh, how lovely.
My headache is back.
That could be the reason.
Oh, wonderful.
But I'm sure I could do even better.
And by that, I mean louder.
I know it's important to be positive, but surely there must
be a limit.
Get rid of him, or I'll leave and take my...
children with me.
That's not the threat you think it is, Philly Jock.
Oh no!
Philly Jockler is gonna leave?
Oh man!
Please, we love it here moment, Troll!
Make him stop so Mother doesn't make us leave!
Oh, I'll see what I can do.
I was hoping we could be more like a family or something.
Surely there must be room for everyone in the mo-
He's causing an avalanche.
Stop that.
So about you staying here?
Are we kicking him out?
Yes, you are welcome.
I was wondering if...
Oh man.
Oh, I thought you were done.
That's it.
We'll be outside.
Fix this!
Yes, Mumen Troll.
Take some responsibility.
In the likely case that you will have to abandon your house,
you can join me for some games in the forest.
What?
So we need a musician for the Great Winter Bonfire
celebration.
Indeed you do.
Luckily, I'm of the conviction that art should be shared
freely.
Yeah, we're voting him off the island for sure.
Yes, but some of the others...
Don't mind them.
You and me, we've got this.
Oh, no.
This guy is just Rick and Morty.
I need you to...
I need you to feel you are properly taken care of,
acoustically speaking.
That makes sense.
These surroundings are suboptimal, and I get interrupted
constantly.
There's a great spot some distance from here.
Yes, up in the mountains.
Wait, no, don't say the mountains.
He's actually going to cause an avalanche.
I don't think Moomin knows about avalanches, though.
Where you can unfold artistically.
I don't think Rick and Morty is the comparison you would
make.
No, it's because it's like Moomin is Morty, and then Hemulin
is like, you and me, Moomin forever.
You and me, Moomin and Hemulin, always.
You and me, six seasons in a movie.
However, I do need some provisions.
Could you grab my lunchbox for me?
That sounds like an easy enough task.
Oh.
A bird took it from me.
Flew away with it towards the bathing house.
Oh my gosh.
Moomin is getting his steps in today.
Holy cow.
Yeah, I don't get it.
You know what?
I get it.
The duality.
You guys don't always have to understand the workings of my
mind.
that it works.
Meet me by the old shack down by the beach.
No time to lose.
Step one.
Get lunchbox from Bird.
Step two.
Bring Spring back.
Oh,
it's quiet again.
Finally, some peace and quiet.
She's smiling.
Missabelle is smiling.
How are you doing, Ancestor?
Do you like Music?
So true.
I've always wondered how hibernation works.
Like, how do you not wake up?
How does that happen?
Okay, he's gone.
He can go back in now.
Thank heavens the amulet went to the beach.
He can bother two tickies instead.
It works in fantastic ways.
The forest.
I'm guessing the forest is where the bonfire is, is where
Little Mae was talking about.
That's the neat part.
They can wake up.
Oh, they don't sleep the whole time, really?
They do wake up.
They're just very heavy sleepers.
Only for, like, bathroom breaks and stuff.
Really?
I love seeing a big fat squirrel with nuts in his cheeks.
Oh, he's, oh, God, he's playing it here.
I can hear him.
I'm so sorry.
What is the emulant doing here?
Loudly looking for his lunchbox.
Nobody wants him around.
Everybody is sick of him.
Where's the bird?
Oh, there it is.
Where'd he come from?
There it is, that greedy bird, mindlessly feasting on the
food of others.
Throw a warning snowball and make it lose in its grip.
I do it myself, but I can't risk my tuba hands at this
point.
Oh, I'm good at getting these guys.
They don't know what'll, he won't know what'll hit him.
Yeah.
Easy.
Okay, shut up, please.
Shut up, please.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to body slam him.
Bobo update.
Still, don't beat the Bobo.
Thank you.
I have a long as a bird.
But I have a Phoebe Bobo.
She was easier because she doesn't need to be a ghost.
Good luck!
Here is your lunchbox.
Perfect.
No more obstacles.
All is ready for my trip.
No.
Cool.
Wait, what's happening?
Whoa, another obstacle!
Guys, it's time for the axe for real.
Not sure you tried to kill me.
If I didn't know any better, I'd say the lady of the cold
had it in for me.
I'd say so too.
Take Moomin Papa's axe.
I mean, my...
Everybody just steals...
From Moomin's family!
Deal with it, I need to save my wind for the horn.
What were you doing with Moomin Papa's axe?
Well, he wasn't exactly pulling his weight around the house
now, was he?
Oh my god.
Hurry up and get rid of this tree so I can commence
practicing.
I don't know.
Choosing the axe was always Moomin, Papa's job.
Moomin, little Moomin's growing up so fast.
I might as well go for it since I'm doing all the grown-up
jobs these days anyway.
Oh my gosh.
We get three woods from it.
That felt great.
Wonderful.
Consider the axe a gift from me.
Now if there's nothing more, I'm off to play to the
mountaintops.
Better acoustics, like you said.
It's time to chop, chop, chop.
The mountaintops?
What was all that about?
Possession is nine out of tens of the...
Ten of them.
The others needed some peace and quiet.
They made me get rid of them.
It was either him or them.
Dramatic gasp.
Uh oh.
Oh, what's now?
What now?
Oh.
Get rid of me?
He heard that!
Oh, oh.
Peace?
Quiet?
Oh, this negativity.
It's like I taught you nothing!
Oh!
My gifts obviously aren't appreciated.
Camulon, I'm so sorry!
We really need you at the great winter bonfire.
Well, I'll be there, alright.
Playing four times as hard as previously announced.
up to six times more spring back than all of you combined do
we really I guess so we need a musician oh too ticky I feel
bad about this yes change however often comes with the price
of sacrifice what does that mean what do you mean by that
what too ticky stop stop with your wisdom dumb right now how
did he hear should have his ears be shot right speaking of
with your axe you can start removing fallen trees there are
several around doing so makes room for new plants to grow as
well as providing you with much needed firewood we have to
sacrifice him to change if you could if you clean up the
area.
I'm sure I have a reward lying around for later.
Oh my gosh.
Find a musician, but we don't?
But we didn't?
Oh, remove the trees.
I was gonna do it anyway.
Nice.
Wait, this one only yielded two wood.
Oh, some of them yield... Oh, just kidding.
Very nice.
This one?
I'm on board.
Wait, does it, can we get the boat?
No.
Where else are other ones?
Am I crazy?
Is there some up here?
No.
Uh, axe the bird.
Bird murder is always right.
No, I love birds.
Don't, don't.
I didn't mean what I said.
It just came out.
I think I was possessed.
Murder.
A murder of crows is not a suggestion.
It is a...
It is a must.
It is a command.
What is this thing?
Oh, that was a vase piece.
Okay.
Wait, there's still one more?
Oh, I see it.
I...
Wait, I completely missed this entire big snowy area.
Uh, right here.
Oh my goodness.
I completely missed this area.
There's so much snow here.
Stairs at you with PN eyes.
I love watching bird videos.
Like Corvids?
Corvids are so crazy to watch.
because they're just so stinking smart, you know?
I want to befriend one with a nickel.
They're so smart.
And the way they talk, like, I think it's very funny that,
like, you know, how they imitate speech and everything.
And, like, there's stories of, like, funny, I used to post
poem chores like this, but they could be so much fun.
But there's, like, stories of, like, People hearing voices
in the woods and things like that.
But for all you know, I mean, it could be me.
Or it could be a Corvid.
Just imitating your speech.
That should be all of the fallen trees.
Wonderful.
Preparing for spring is like preparing for guests.
The ritual can be joyful in itself.
I've got a little something for you.
It's not much, but I thought of you and I found it.
That vase, Moomin' Mama, is so proud of.
Oh, no, it's another piece.
That is from Moomin' Mama's vase.
I've been looking for these pieces all over.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you for the donation of the Moomin' vase.
Gosh, it really makes me want to add the sound back.
It's so nostalgic.
My children, help!
Wait, what's going on?
The Lady of the Cold has been added again?
hmm somebody is yelling from the movement house it sounded
like or it sounds like philly junk oh oh no what is the lady
of the cold doing i said i was gonna stop this game but it's
also like addicting you know what i mean hold on philly junk
i have some some stuff to have some wood to cut first i once
saw a video of a bird mimicking a camera shutter sound
really crazy nice
oh yeah our our wood production is speeding up like crazy
now yes yes exactly what I wanted and then this we can
explore oh there's probably if I had to guess a vase piece
in here
scrap metal ideal for making a shovel sturdier.
Huge?
Wait.
Wait, that's actually big.
I don't think there was anything else over here.
Upgrades.
Okay, before we go back home, we'll go to there.
Okay, yeah.
We'll go make our... Wait, what?
If we make our shovel stronger, you think that can get the
ice?
Rather than an ice pick?
camera shutter when i know it was a liar word
huh nothing really stingy bushes
i think i think the getting the ice is the last thing that
we need so my children what's wrong with my game why is it
flickering guys i'm nervous about deadly premonition
RL.
Congrats on your 4444 subscriber.
You've on a great journey ahead of you to solitary.
Anyway, joke aside, really happy to see your growth.
Thank you, Nan.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it so much.
Thank you.
I'm Scrap Metal.
This is perfect for making your shovel a bit more sturdy.
Be right back.
I don't know if it's Switch or OBS.
I don't think I'm flickering.
I think just the capture is flickering, no?
Your shovel should be a lot more efficient now.
Thank you, Tootiki.
Stronger shovel.
Maybe it's just...
Maybe it shovels better now.
Maybe it digs better now.
You're fine, it's just a game.
I'm concerned if it's either my...
It could be like one of three things.
It could be my Switch itself.
It was...
Before I started the game, my Switch was going like...
The... What's it called on it?
The fan on it was going crazy.
It was like super worrying.
So I was like, oh, okay.
Hefty game.
So it could be the Switch itself.
It could be my capture card or maybe like the cord.
Hmm.
My children!
If it happens with other games, then you know, yeah.
What happened?
My children were eaten by the crook!
Or at least having unsupervised fun, which is basically the
same thing.
Wait, what?
I'm sure they're fine.
They actually seem to be enjoying the season.
This is your fault.
All this reckless talk of bonfires, free love, and
rebellion.
Time to get a switch to...
No!
I'll go look for them.
Hurry!
Nature is no place for children.
Mother isn't here now.
Children will listen.
Uh, bonfire.
Oh, so did they get eaten or not?
Has it been dusty lately?
It has been, because I'm moving so much stuff.
I'm moving so much stuff.
Oh, I love this song.
This song is...
The music is just too good.
Oh, hello.
You came!
Hope this fire will warm you.
Fire warm you.
Weewee Valley, weewee.
Movement Valley.
Let's hope so.
Weewee dance good.
Big weewee fire dance.
Weewee soon, weewee.
So glad you got to rehearse.
I can't wait to see your dance around the great winter
bonfire.
Wait, is this the forest we're going into?
Oh, no it's not.
Is this not the forest?
Hold on.
the map.
Oh yeah, yeah.
We're going to the forest.
Spooky, scary area over there, yeah.
Three sets of footprints.
The children must have come this way.
That guy is still hungry.
Sorry, I haven't been able to find food for you.
Or myself, apparently.
If I find food, I get, um,
Oh yeah, and we have to light these poles.
That was another mission.
Cool, cool, cool.
Yay, new area!
Oh my gosh, how exciting.
Billy Junk's children should be this way.
Little Mai looks cookable.
There she is.
What are you doing here?
Look who's back for one, Morgan.
No, no!
I can't now.
Too bad.
I was really stoked on that whole bonfire thing, but I guess
they have others to help you.
Little Mai, you promised you would help me.
Her head looks like an onion.
It's the best part.
Yes, but this time I actually promise.
One more game, and I swear you will be better off after
playing this.
How?
Because I'll give you some sweet firewood.
You might even recognize it.
From my pockets?
Did you take that from the movement house?
Yes, you were hoarding it selfishly, not realizing it could
also be used for fun.
She's such a brat!
I've hidden a pile of firewood under the snow.
Get closer to it and I'll save warmer.
Further away and it's colder.
I don't want to play.
I know, that's why I'm kind of forcing you.
I guess you'll leave me no choice.
Moomin literally ages.
Holder.
I'm literally on it.
Movement ages 50 years when he talks to her.
Colder.
Up here?
Warmer?
We're getting warmer?
Hot, hot, hot?
Uh...
Colder.
Moomin is tired.
Moomin has become the only adult in this... in the valley
now.
We can't take it anymore.
It's gotta be this one.
That little my...
Oh wait, the children!
I must not lose focus!
I hope the children are alright.
I better start looking for them.
Never put Moomin on the search team, search and rescue team,
you guys.
What about Moomin?
He's just a child, too.
He's just a little baby.
Hold on, we'll light this.
It's part of the...
Oh, shoot.
Come on.
There we go.
Nice.
It's part of the mission.
We gotta light all the torches.
Nice.
These winter beings are fascinating.
They seem to have friends, family, worries, just like me.
That's it.
You found it.
Thanks for taking all the fun out of the game.
Actually, I kind of wanted since you agreed to play.
That was my goal all along.
Also, all you had to do was wait for spring and the firewood
would simply reappear.
Serves you well for being such a go-getter.
She scampers away.
How is so fun.
Almost made me forget about the horrors of winter.
Not the horrors of winter.
How got work to do.
And yeah, we have children that are apparently being eaten
or something.
We gotta get those guys.
Move in.
The children!
Won't somebody think of the children?
The time, the most applicable time ever.
Dang, holy cow, our shovel is so efficient.
Gareth!
So welcome to membership, thank you!
Hayao!
Uh...
What's going on?
Wee!
Snow is wonderful!
Does this mean mint is moomin now?
I'm always moomin.
You're not lost after all, you're just playing in the snow!
Moomin hunting down the children in the woods with an ant.
however you're i know they love being buried in the snow
have you noticed that ever since that first kid that got
avalancheed in they're like yeah i don't mind the
suffocation
let's go to the bonfire site catch me if you can
find the children under the snow you guys don't understand i
just got an upgrade I can find anything, anyone.
What is that?
Oh,
I see.
Okay, I need to knock the tree down so I can go over there
and light the other torch.
I think they're only moving where the snow is still deep.
And soon they'll have no other options.
If I keep clearing it away, there will be nowhere left to
run.
Yeah!
I got one kid.
Now, Whack him.
There.
You're safe now.
Go to the bonfire site while I find your siblings.
Huh?
All right, party pooper.
I was getting cold anyway.
Moomin is acting like such an adult now.
Hmm.
I should look for the other children.
Moomin is finally the party pooper.
He's like, I gotta shovel snow.
And I've gotta.
I've gotta.
I've gotta make build bridges.
Out of snow.
He's gotta, yeah, he's gotta be the only responsible one
here in this valley.
His parents are to round.
They're sleeping on the job.
They'll be so proud of him, though, once they wake up.
See that all he's done.
Snow, snow, slow.
Soon he has to pay taxes.
No, we're making, we're making these kids grow up.
up too fast.
That that tree fell.
It might land just right.
Yeah, and it did.
Cool.
Has Moomin become Unk?
I think so, actually.
Oh my god, my little Moomin grows up too fast.
These kids need to be kids.
Yes.
Uh oh, now they're playing, the children are playing in the
caves.
Has it just been one day?
This is insane.
Oh my goodness.
Let's go this way.
Woohoo!
This is fun!
The longest day.
What's this kid doing?
Get down from there!
It's dangerous!
You're gonna...
I don't know.
You're gonna do something.
You're gonna crack your skull.
Humpty Dumpty style.
Oh no, come down!
No!
I like it up here.
I have a bird's eye view of everything!
Much unlike a bird, however, I don't have the capacity to
fly.
So I'm staying.
Come on, I haven't got all day.
I have!
Hmm.
There must be some way of getting them down.
I'll huff.
And I'll puff.
And I'll chop down this tree and go up there and get you
myself, mister.
Go home.
For a while there, I felt like I was on top of the world.
That must be what adults feel like all the time.
I wouldn't know.
Now go straight to the bonfire site and do not dally.
Poor Dilly.
You used to be fun.
Now you sound like my mother.
The winters are cruel.
The winters are harsh.
You wouldn't know, little kid.
You've never experienced.
What the lady of the cold can do.
I saw death before my very eyes.
His body's stiff.
Wait, we gotta go back and see what that rope...
Actually, I want to go see what the rope, the rope might be
like an escape route, but I'm not quite sure, so.
This is really a story about growing up.
It is.
Responsibility is in stock.
Yuck.
Yeah, at the very beginning of this game, it started with
the death of a squirrel.
And that guy froze to death.
His body is...
His stiff little...
Okay, cool, we can get that too.
I should have gotten that first, dang it.
Oh well.
What's going on here?
Wait, what is going on here?
What do you have?
Why are you flying around?
I didn't see if he was holding on to anything.
Oh, he is!
There we go.
Actually, there's several things here.
We got another piece of wood.
Oh my gosh, we have to bring it all the way over here.
Okay.
Yeah, piece of vice.
Diamond of vice.
All right.
Onwards.
Why does the bird sound like that?
It sounds so distressed.
Okay.
All right, cool.
There are several things down here.
Very nice.
Winter beings are fascinating.
Yeah, they're just like you, Moorman.
They're just like you.
I don't know if this is helping, but the forest feels more
welcoming, for sure.
Yeah, I hit him with two snowballs.
He has brain damage.
Brain...
It runs in the bloodline.
The brain damage lasts for generations.
Every bird in Moomin Valley.
I'm getting so sleepy.
I said I was going to stop a while ago, but I'm also so
hungry.
But I'm also determined to just like, I like, to start the
bonfire.
I can't stop.
I'm enjoying a It's so nice.
It's just...
Try to catch me!
Oh, I know this game.
Oh, he's in there, okay.
Where'd he go?
Oh, so close.
We almost had him.
We gotta cut off his pathways.
There's less places to run.
Yeah.
Wait!
I got him!
Got you!
Meet the children by the bonfire, but alright.
Let's get rid of all this though.
I might have some other stuff around here.
Actually, this is quite the area.
What is he holding?
Wait, what is he holding?
Oh.
The diary!
He's holding the diary.
I should get the diary back to the winter being!
Page is full of secrets.
Dang.
It won't let me.
Letter from Snuffkin.
I miss you, Snuffkin.
Binto, don't do it.
gonna actually read it i just wanted to see if it was
possible what secrets we might not even they don't they
don't speak our language entirely so we probably wouldn't
even be able to understand it you know no big deal
i threaded the needle
Surely there's a...
Uh, wait.
Oh, what?
A shortcut back home, surely.
How many?
98!
Oh my gosh, we're at 98 out of...
out of 125!
Guys, we're so close actually.
I'll keep digging.
The dogen!
Yeah, the diary!
Can you snowball the snowy trees?
The ones that I slam into?
No.
You can only body slam them.
Wow, I don't think there was a single one under there.
That's so lame.
Now, what's up here?
No, no, no, no, I can say, yeah.
Wait, but...
There was something over here, too.
But what could it be?
Will this get me back up, I think?
Oh, I think it's to ice pick this.
And then it would go back up, I think, as the...
Oh, this is also an exit, though.
Where's this going?
Oh.
Shortcut?
Shortcut.
Look how cute it's in the shape of a heart.
It's in the shape of a heart, you guys.
Wait, before we, let's see what was in that other way
though.
How cute!
Oh, wait, we gotta go back up this way.
This way.
Alright.
We're...
We will explore every part of Moomin Valley.
Without fail.
Oh, this is a place we haven't been before.
With lots of wood.
Get me.
Just 25.
Oh, and here's the last one too!
Oh, I think this is the friend that's also scared of the
dark.
This guy right here.
Found you.
Will you join the others now?
We, we, we, troll good.
We, self, we, hide good.
Again?
Oh, is this the guy playing hide and seek?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
He's been there for hours.
Okay.
Okay, now we can leave.
Okay, good.
It's a good thing we went that way.
Also, we're better at, like, rolling down those icy paths
now.
We don't tumble.
Have you noticed that, too?
We really are growing.
Because we're not, like, stumbling our way down anymore.
We're competent.
It's so sweet.
He's growing up.
Hello.
We, we, forest light.
Forest warm, we.
We, happy, friend, happy we.
I'm glad I can help your friend.
We, friend, help friend.
That's what it's all about.
We, we, friend, gift.
We, troll, we, we.
What?
For me?
Firewood?
It's actually the perfect gift.
Thank you.
Or I mean, tell your friend I said thanks.
I could use this for the great winter bonfire.
I hope to see you and your friend there.
Scamper's off.
That's the last of the winter beings.
They should be able to attend the bonfire now.
Oh, it's help three of them.
That's all of you.
Time to go home to your mother.
She's worried sick.
But she's...
She's so strict.
Only because she loves you.
And she's also a freak and cares about her figurines more
than her children.
You should be happy you have a mother that's awakened
looking out for you.
Don't guilt trip that moon red.
I do miss her.
And we're rather cold, it seems.
It did not help that we decided to build a humongous snow
pile.
Boo.
Well, look at how big it is.
I believe it will be the world's largest.
Nice elephant impression.
My darlings, you're safe.
Oh, how I've missed you.
We had an Avenger mother.
They said she only has one figurine but three kids.
She did have like five figurines.
Until Moomin Troll saved us from it.
You seem mostly unharmed.
I guess a thank you is in place.
Oh, no need.
But if you would reconsider coming to the Great Winter
Bonfire, another adventure!
Please, Mother!
Wee!
Wee, Mother, please, wee!
Oh, Ible, Ible, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, could
wee, please go to the big bonfire, wee!
another adventure you still haven't gotten it out of your
system very well I guess we could schedule in some fun and
games I'll allow it oh my gosh he's allowing fun and games
what were you doing here in the first place we were
exploring the great unknown right outside of Moom and the
house primarily the great unknown the
great unknown Then we heard a dog in the forest.
We went looking for it, but I think we scared it off.
She has such lemon grab energy.
Now it's lost, and it's our fault.
Can you find it for us?
Yes.
Please, Mumentral, you're the bravest friend we have.
Mia, well, in that case, I guess I'll go looking for her.
The dog.
It went that way.
Jumped right over that gap there.
Hmm.
Oh, I can't do that.
Maybe you can make a snowball from the world's largest snow
pile.
What about all of the snow that I've been shoveling?
Is that not the largest?
I saw it first.
No, no, it was me.
Oh, they're talking.
I saw it.
saw it before both of you.
Now, time to get...
Time to find that dog, then I'll get back to my bonfire
preparation.
Why does it... Why did it feel like it was giving me a
tutorial of, like, how to...
How to use this, you know?
The snow pile.
Am I...
I don't feel like I'm...
I'm like Snuffkin!
Oh, dear Snuffkin!
Movement has a lot to say right now.
I don't feel like I'm going out of order like I'm doing so
much before I don't think so what else can we do stuck in
the eyes that guy in the eyes a winter being is frozen in
the ice and its eyes are pleading for help oh nope I've
helped three guys I don't need to help anymore we had to go
back to that guy and give him his diary winter being oh we
can go get the lost friend because we have the axe now.
Maybe we should go to the mountain then.
Creatures waiting for a message in a bottle.
Hide and seek with that one guy.
Hungry winter waiting to eat.
And the vase.
Let's go to the mountain real quick.
Oh look.
Oh look at this little... I like how you can see their foot
tracks.
It's like so cute.
Actually we'll see if we need to go back to the mountain for
anything else.
Probably the guy that is playing his...
What was it?
French horn?
Alright, new area.
Let's go.
Game is full of nice details.
I think so too.
Game is so nice.
I like the music so much.
Was it a tuba?
It was a tuba?
Oh, my bad.
I couldn't remember what it was playing.
Oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa!
Wind is so strong, I should find cover.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Oh, no, I'm not gonna make it!
Oh.
Hello?
Dog?
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo!
Mr. Dog?
Okay, it gives you a warning, at least.
Here it comes!
I'll just follow his steps.
Never mind.
Oh my gosh, I'm not gonna make it.
I was trying to follow the dog.
I wonder if you can check the house pantry for food.
I feel bad for the guy that's hungry.
Okay.
This rock right...
Wow, I wonder if we can make it to the next one.
Gert cough!
Do not fear me cough!
It's a bit cold here even for a dangerous wolf like me.
Oh, it wasn't not a dog.
Oh!
Oh, did we just get double raided?
Becky!
Looking for the raid!
A wolf, I thought I was looking for a dog.
Many have made that mistake.
Most people come to think of it.
Desiree, thank you so much for the raid.
Becky, thank you for the raid!
Hiyobuckas!
Wait, what was Vicky doing today?
Was she?
Was it Devil May Cry?
Missing Glitch Face, thank you, paperbacks, thank you!
I guess she have to thank you!
It was the MC3!
Is Vicky gaming through it?
I believe.
Missing Glitch Face, thank you!
She beat Beowulf!
I remember that.
Hello!
Have a good stream!
Thank you!
I'm glad I did.
by a wolf was whoof.
Thank you, Fistroop.
Thank you.
Dorko, thank you.
Phil, thank you.
Now we'll thank you.
Yeah, it's cozy hours here with movement, so you can rest a
little.
We're saving a dog.
Or wolf?
Hi there, dog.
Yes, this is dog.
I mean wolf.
Grr.
You don't look much like a wolf.
I do.
On a regular day.
I am quite intimidating.
But today I have a cold.
Beowulf is tough, yeah.
The name is Saurioed, by the way.
As in, people are Saurioed across my path, I think.
I didn't come up with it.
Oh my gosh, wait, Beowulf?
And we're rescuing a wolf.
How perfect.
Lumen roll.
Now let's carry you to safety.
Here, I'll carry you.
I'll get you to safety.
I shall allow it, although this is uncommon practice amongst
wolves.
Bravely I am carried to my death.
You'll be fine.
Stay strong.
Never have I asked for an easy burden.
Only a strong back.
All right.
Here?
Oh no.
Oh no, no!
Everything's fine.
Maybe in here?
I'm getting you!
I'm getting you out!
I have to put you down, though.
I can't use my hands while carrying this dog!
Wolf.
I should place him on the ground for a bit.
He's like calling out for help.
Shut up, I'm right here!
He's so needy.
He's like, I'd wish not to be carried.
And yet.
Had to work yesterday, but can I be good?
Bladed, happy birthday.
Eventually goes, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
So sorry, you had to work on your birthday.
But...
Welcome, thank you.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Wait, right here.
probably.
I'll have to put you down again, sorry.
For my hat, or for my shovel.
You're lucky I got the upgrade, buddy.
Because otherwise, you'd be in bad shape.
This would take a lot longer.
Ah, you guys are so sweet and wishing everybody happy
birthdays.
The music feels so dramatic, no?
So what were you doing out here all by yourself?
I was looking for my tribe.
I was looking for a wolf pack, as it turns out they were not
recruiting at the moment.
Oh no!
In fact, they showed no interest in me except perhaps as a
culinary treat!
Oh no!
Sad to hear, we all need to belong somewhere.
Perhaps I'm just a lone wolf.
Dependent on no one.
No!
That's so sad.
Perhaps.
Let me carry you to safety.
You're a true friend of the wolves.
Another rid!
Oh my goodness!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, I need to go over here, I think.
Put the dog down.
Don't get blown away.
Hello, everybody.
We're comfy movement hours.
Comfy movement time.
Actually, maybe I could have made that.
I didn't realize.
Darygo, thank you.
You guys don't have to keep sending gifted.
It's okay.
Thank you, though.
Oh, I keep pressing the wrong button.
I guess they have to thank you.
I gotta chop this down.
Oh my goodness, stop whining!
Grape, thank you so much for the ride.
Thank you!
I hope you had a fun stream, whatever you were doing.
We're cozy hours today, because I don't feel so good.
I think I can make it?
No.
Wolf sounds like ice whipping kids one second wait for
stream.
pretty much I can make it I can't make it I'm not gonna make
it abandoned neglected I got saved by the frames of working
on the thing oh my gosh that's crazy you're possibly a
candidate for my new wolf pack thank you I'm honored hmm is
there no end to this winter?
The lady of the cold shows no mercy.
Ah, well, thank you!
Eye frames are crazy.
Eye frames and Moomin' Gim.
You heard it here first, folks.
Pro-gamer skills.
Sorry, I don't mean to...
Please don't think I'm rolling over you with...
Nice.
We continue onward.
This is a long way through the forest.
Holy...
There's more?
Oh, jeez.
Okay.
Just go, just go!
Oh, shoot.
Oops.
Don't go.
Don't just go.
Try to be strategic.
Okay, never mind.
You can go.
Ice level.
Don't go.
I can't believe I'm not getting piles of wood from doing
this.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, no!
No!
I left the dog!
Oh, my God, I actually abandoned him.
Where are you going?
I'm sorry.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
He's yelling at me!
I'm sorry!
Oh my gosh, I tumbled again.
Wait!
Oh, there's two separate ones right there.
Oops, sorry.
Come here, come here.
Yes!
Now go, okay.
Now this one...
How does this one work?
Oh, I see.
Don't get too greedy now.
Okay, go, go, go.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
I can't wait for this winter nightmare to be over and for
Mormon mama and Mormon papa to wake up.
Which way am I going?
Oh, I think to the... Okay.
We made it!
We're beating the children's game!
I think we're getting close to the end.
Thank goodness, please.
No!
I was so close.
Come here, dog.
Come here.
Dominating the children's game.
Oh, yeah, oh, yeah.
We're close.
Protect the...
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh, I messed up.
I'll get you in a second.
I'm here!
right next to you!
I couldn't go through!
Uh-oh.
Wait, don't go, don't go, don't go.
Look at it.
Oh my gosh, how?
How?
Okay.
I was behind the rock.
Alright, we're almost there.
Okay, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Little dog.
Alright, we gotta run through.
Oh, okay.
I thought this was a tiny rock, but it's actually quite
large.
Cuff, cuff.
We'll make it!
I'm not gonna let you freeze like the...
like the squirrel.
They give you just enough time to get to the next rock.
I wish I could get to another one.
No.
Uh...
Oh, it starts right there.
Okay, we can leave after this.
Let's get you back to the movement house!
That sounds nice.
They patted the heck out of this game.
With some of these sections.
Holy canoli.
They were like, yeah.
This game takes six hours.
You found the dog.
Yes, his name is Sauru.
He seems to have gotten a cold.
Basically a death sentence.
But I'll get over it.
I should lay Sauru on the...
carpet there so he can rest oh it's like it was made for him
get that filthy dog away from me and what the hell are you
you're like a clown mongoose a clown badger excuse me you're
are you are you not a creature yourself Filthy wolf, thanks.
It's sick?
What if my children get sick too?
Movement troll do something.
It's just a common cold, I think.
A common cold?
The silent killer.
My children can't take care of a pet, let alone a sick one.
Stop talking about him like he isn't here.
You poor thing.
abandoned cold i know exactly how you're feeling i've been
under the weather myself a lot luckily there are some herbs
that can help you with that nasty cold of yours miss a bell
herbs where not so easily accessible in the winter but
there's a cave east of here a shelter that should have the
right growing conditions you hear that moment troll need to
go gather some herbs but i just got in It's the least you
can do.
Oh my gosh.
I'll mark the cave on the map for you.
You truly fear nothing, Moment troll.
Death traps, wolves are incredibly dangerous and most likely
haunted caves.
You're such an inspiration.
I am.
You should sharpen your axe before leaving.
Yes, in case of monsters.
Have this wet stone.
Mother won't let us play with sharp objects.
I wonder if this is what will break the ice.
Thank you.
If only I knew how to use it.
I should probably ask.
Tootiki!
Tootiki, tootiki, tootiki, tootiki, tootiki, tootiki,
tootiki, tootiki.
Look at you.
We'll get you back on your feet.
Find medicinal herbs in the cave.
Alright.
Why does the children have a wet stone?
They found it in the woods, obviously.
Well, while rummaging around in the snow.
Wait, why did I have to find the herbs?
Yeah, why did I have to find the herbs?
Why can't someone else do it?
Philly Junk probably has a lot to do.
She doesn't, but sure.
This is why movements hibernate to avoid all this.
Literally everybody just puts them to work.
I'm doing all of this so I can see the Aurora Borealis
during the bonfire.
blue oh my god everybody just asks me to do everything is
this how mama mumin and papa mumin are they're just like we
need we need several months of relaxation because everyone
is so freaking annoying all the time everybody asks us to do
literally everything so we need to actually sleep so nobody
will bother us except they do because everybody just walks
into their home and takes their stuff.
And what's crazy is they do that in the show, too.
Everybody just kind of like goes inside their home while
they're hibernating.
I'm afraid this isn't a social call, Tewtiki.
I need to ask you a favor.
Moom and Papa's old axe are gonna need some sharpening.
They know how to use this wet stone.
Indeed I do.
Way right here.
This should be quick.
Tewtiki is so handy.
Tewtiki is the only reliable one, except they wouldn't let
us save the score.
All we had to do was go out the squirrel where are the
police the police also don't do anything they're so
incompetent there a sharp axe for a steady hand try using it
on that ice block over there i used to be so afraid of sharp
tools now i wonder how i managed without them
snuffkin wouldn't stand for this snuffkin is only is the
only good guy everybody else sucks snuff getting too ticky
our best
They're trying to distract Moomin from his missing parents.
They're not missing!
They're sleeping!
We know exactly where they are!
It works!
Of course it does.
We're gonna break this really quickly though.
Thanks for sharpening my axe.
Now I'm gonna go dull it super quickly by breaking a bunch
of ice.
Only 21 more wood to go.
Yeah.
They're missing.
They're not missing.
They're in their beds.
We're in their bed.
Oh, wait.
Let's go to this one first.
Oh, boy.
He slid over.
He's a maniac.
He wants to.
Oh.
What's this?
It continues.
Wait.
Does this go to the...
outside area that...
Wee!
A rat!
What was that creature?
I didn't expect Moonman Valley neighborhood to be the same
vibes as getting so cute.
Probably just my imagination.
Oh, why can't I imagine nice things instead?
Oh, interesting.
Wait, does this lead to that one area that has the tree that
we can cut down?
No.
Oh, an herb.
that must be an herb
I don't know that's one now I need to find four more
oops just 20 more left holy cow you guys I feel like herbs I
mean herbs could grow here right but I feel like we're
giving the dog some mushrooms or something.
Gonna finish the game this stream?
Honestly, I couldn't tell you.
I might.
But I was supposed to pack.
Hmm.
Can I bust?
Oh, I can break these out now.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we can break everything now!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
Wait, was there nothing out?
Nowhere else to go this way?
Oh.
I know there's a down area, but I don't remember...
It's having any blocks.
Or, like, ice to get rid of down here.
Shouldn't be too much longer.
Yeah, even if we don't get through all the quests and stuff,
that's okay.
That one guy is just going to be frozen in ice, I guess.
Did I miss some area?
Wait, I must have missed an area.
He'll manage.
It must be the That one area I thought was a dead end It's
not actually
This area is actually It feels like With the candles and
stuff It feels like a Japanese ritual type You know, like a
shrine in a cave
Wait, am I crazy?
No, kind of ominous, yeah Oh It's not water.
My bad.
Oh.
Bye, bud.
I feel silly now.
Oopsie.
Come, camera obscura.
Wait.
Hmm.
I think I've picked all the herbs here.
Okay, thank you, woman.
I'm exploring now, buddy.
It's called exploration.
It's my favorite thing.
right you thought it was on frozen water too okay don't feel
as silly then if you guys also saw it too thank you for
validating me making me not feel like such a crazy silly
goose oh
the rat he's dancing it kind of looks like a kangaroo like a
mini kangaroo this creature is starting to annoy me Why?
Why is that moving?
Oh, an herb.
More herb!
Huzzah!
I think the- I wish this game had a little bit of like a
fast travel aspect to it.
Because with the snow and everything you move so slowly.
and so when i'm like oh i have to go to the mountains to i
think you're not supposed to speed run the game you're
supposed to kind of take it at a movement slow pace they
don't want they want you to just kind of take it in and
relax yeah but i'm like let's finish the game i want the
bonfire
they're like you need to you're going at a tokyo pace you
need to go out of finish plate face cave mushroom maybe the
winter being would like some we found a snack we found the
snack okay okay that wasn't what we needed but that was good
I wonder if I could hold on I want to try something real
quick they do seem I'm pretty adamant on making you live
through every action.
Let me see if I can get these.
Knock these down.
Oh, I can.
Wait, there was something else it would let me...
It was locking on.
What was that?
I'm off work, Minto.
And I see you're still moving along.
Still moving along.
Has it been a whole work shift?
Maybe I'm not locking onto anything.
I'm just imagining things.
Alright, what's this way?
As if it's the glowing mushrooms.
It can refill their batteries.
Going to sleep.
Thanks for the cafe's room.
Much love, Tom, Mickey.
Good night, Rob.
Good night.
Thanks for hanging out.
Maybe you gotta go to sleep.
That's okay, everybody.
Are you guys people that leave streams on for sleep.
I definitely, I'll put on a VOD for sleep.
What?
Nothing in here?
Actually?
Wait.
Why?
There is nothing in here.
What was the point of coming in here?
I guess there was one wood.
You visual novels or JRPGs?
Hmm.
Can't sleep with noise.
I can't sleep without noise.
I hope so are you will get well from these herbs Yeah, me
too
Is it under here?
Oh yes Alright, there's two more
Fan for white Fan for white noise
I need people talking That's my thing Is I I need like A
conversation happening No more herbs hiding around here.
Better get a move on.
Hold on.
There's wood, though.
Movement.
You're the one being impatient now.
My goodness.
They're like, the game should be completed at a slow pace
where you take in a...
Like, the game is so pretty.
Don't get me wrong.
Eek.
But...
What a strange little creature.
Okay.
But then they're like, hey, get a move on, pal.
Your friend is dying.
Where are we anyway?
That's good audio design, too.
Yeah, I agree.
It's a cute little game for sure.
And it was $20?
Like, not bad at all.
Because it looks like art, you know?
Like, hello.
I almost saw you.
Hmm.
The creature went in there.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
There.
He was!
He was the hide-and-seek!
I need to have someone saying stuff in the background so I
can start slowly ignoring them as I drift out.
That's me too!
Me too!
When YouTube Rewind came out last year, Nancy Drew was my
number one most watched game because I would always put your
streams on what I went to bed.
Anik, thank you.
Well, I should do another Nancy stream then, huh?
So you can have some new material.
Troll friend.
Wee, wee, friend play.
Hi.
Oh, hi.
Oh, my God.
Moomin's going to punch this guy.
Me and apparently quite a few people listen to this Age of
Empires caster when sleeping and he kind of hates it because
he feels like he's boring because of it.
I understand the sentiment.
but also I don't care if someone's like I put on Ninky to
sleep I'm like oh well a view's a view well maybe I should
be playing more alright one more time and then play time's
over are we for real right now we gotta get this guy one
more time boom and don't indulge him
Moomin, he's playing you like a fiddle.
Minto streams end up 1 a.m., so I end up falling asleep
quite often.
Sorry they end so late.
That means they begin late for you, too.
Sorry.
Can't go wrong with falling asleep to Minto ASMR.
This is where the creature went, right?
Oh no!
This herb has been picked already.
Someone's been here.
Hey, I need that.
Hey, come back with that herb.
I need it for my sick friend.
Well, what if he needs it for his sick friend?
Hello?
Who's there?
Kind of creepy.
I feel like I'm being a stalker serial killer.
Why are you running away?
Is this a game?
Little creature.
Why are you running?
Oh my gosh.
Moomin, stop being so creepy.
Little creature.
I could step on your tail at this point.
To Moomin House.
You caught me.
What a fun game.
Here are your herbs.
Come back with that herb and then live in my house and steal
my stuff.
means we're friends what do you want to do now oh hi I'm
movement troll pull out the axe for max above yes me too
basically unless you need me to be something else you are me
you are me I'm
very adaptable which makes me a great candidate for a friend
oh well it looks like you well you look like a great friend
and I look like a stalker thanks I've copied it from you so
back at you hmm however the don't oh here it comes nice
going shadow you should have copied better no poor guy hmm
the rat's name is shadow oh no vicky don't look i'm dealing
with life and death situation at the moment that sounds like
a lot to bear even for me i can only copy so far to our
friend group after that it's a rather wonderful bunch huh
there's one in particular you'd like to meet he's been
looking for company for a while that's incredible i'm not
picky hope they're not either by the way if you need to get
back to the moment house this exit is right here thank you
we will do that our life and death situation is happening
but let me check this first
explore in here.
We're so close to having enough wood.
And I wonder, once we have enough wood, do we... do we win?
Because...
Oh!
Nice advice.
Okay, Mumen house exit.
Wasn't it Mumen who just said it was a common cold?
I know, right?
Now we're acting like it's a life or death situation.
Sure, Mumen.
Sure.
Oh, the music is cute.
I'm assuming after you get everything you need, you can
trigger the bonfire whenever you want.
That seems...
That's what I'm thinking, too.
Oh, it does leave here!
That's what I was hoping.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Actually, where are we?
I really think Sauri and Shadow would hit it off.
I can't wait to introduce them.
I thought this was by the ocean.
back straight to my house sorry it was not in shape for a
new acquaintances yet however I should bring him these herbs
first like we're I didn't even realize I was right there I
forgot I think oh I haven't had dinner yet you guys I'm so
hungry it's midnight here's your herbs I grow weaker yeah
didn't mind dying moments why everything seems so clear to
me I have lived a daring life.
A lonely one.
In the face of death, I realize.
A life not shared is no life at all.
Ah, there he is.
The harbinger.
Harbinger.
Harba, harba, harba, harba.
The round-snouted phantom.
I have a pointy nose of the end.
Ah, harbinger.
Harbinger.
it's only me moment troll I found the herbs how wonderful
these will get you back in shape in no time so are you I
feel strong again strong as a wolf no stronger life has
returned I've been given a second chance huh that's great so
are you also I found someone who'd like to meet you a
possible friend herbbringer I can see why I am strong leader
type after all.
I do miss my pack.
Maybe we should go, would look for an alternate, alternative
pack?
Huh.
I'll go tell him to meet you.
I'll be right back.
First, first, rest more.
More rest.
Remember what you've been through, so are you.
You walked me through the valley of death, Misabel.
You showed me, showed remarkable courage in the fight.
Okay, let's go get his friend.
I think he's in love with her.
I think he's in love.
It's just oregano.
I have a nose.
You can see it right there.
How else would I hold these glasses up on my face?
I feel bad about leaving Shadow, but now I can make it up to
him.
Okay, to be fair, you left him for like five seconds, so...
I think he's okay.
I think he's all good.
Oh my gosh, I thought I just felt a hole in my favorite
socks.
Hey, Shadow.
I found somebody who would like to meet you.
They're back at the Moomin House.
Come follow me, and...
No time to lose.
Here I come, friend.
So cute.
A friend.
This is the best day of my life.
No better.
So cute.
I like the way he goes.
I feel like we can deliver the food.
Getting up to the top of the mountain for the diary might be
kind of tough.
And we can save that other guy.
Here, let's go do that real quick.
Let's go save that guy.
Oh, wait.
What is this one?
What's this one?
I haven't been able to go this way before.
We have a shortcut rope for the mountain.
Do we?
I wonder if this is...
Like a lot...
It says mountain base.
It's loading.
This is a totally new area.
No, it's not.
I'm a liar.
I think the guy that's trapped is like right here.
No, he's not.
I don't know where he is.
Wait, I think actually this leads to the top.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
21 out of 25.
Just four left.
I think this goes to the top.
Right?
The guy with the journal is like, should be right up here.
Can I even get to him?
I'm lost.
Wait, let me look at my map.
Can I... I want to enable a pointer on this guy.
Wait, maybe on the quest I can do it.
Uh, secrets in the opener.
I don't know if something's happening, but I'm not sure
what.
Hmm.
maybe this way
yes okay we found them okay good then if i go the other
other mountain entrance i think that leads me to the uh the
guy that needs help here's your diary i didn't peek i
promise i troll we we good we self bad we we oh i don't know
about that i once scared a squirrel and come to think of it
i threw a snowball at a bird oh we we burn book troll help
we we oh you want me to burn the diary i guess i could what
what did this guy write in here that he needs to burn it
doesn't feel right we we book bad we we oh book go weird bad
go weird huh i see well it helps you get rid of
Light the diary on fire.
Why don't we burn it at the bonfire?
We warm.
I hope you're feeling better.
If not, I have an idea for you.
How about you start a new diary and fill it with good deeds?
Wrote the vilest doomedy howie imaginable.
What horrible, shameful fanfic.
smut known to man.
Wee-wee-troll, wee-wee-gudge, wee-wee-troll-wee-wee-I can't
even keep track of the wee-wees anymore.
Help me the help.
Don't need a gift.
Is that a piece of movement mama's base?
I would love to have that.
Thank you.
Help to see you at the Great Winter Bonfire.
We still need 10 base pieces, though.
That's kind of a lot.
I don't know if we'll complete that quest.
That's okay, though.
It's too steep, I should find another way.
Oh, okay.
This way, then.
Yeah, 10 is a lot.
10 is a lot for that.
So that's okay.
Oh, that's right, we came in through my window.
I was like, how did I get over there?
Wait, I didn't mean to do that.
The loading times are so long.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Good?
Okay.
It scared me for a second.
I love the music in the...
This game is so cute.
So cozy.
Oh, wait, we made it back here.
Is this my new friend?
She seems very uptight and stern.
I can't wait to spend the rest of my...
life with her what is this thing woman troll get it away
from me I think I think we should all vote Junkler out of
the house already we're bantering incredible I love shadow
that's not her shadow Philly Junk is more of a advanced
friend such a nice way of putting it I was thinking of sorry
you here sorry you This sounds great.
Wait, where is he?
He was just here.
They got a new dad.
Woman troll.
Sorry, you ran away.
He said he wanted to rejoin his pack.
I'm deeply concerned about him.
His pack?
The wolves?
Oh, no.
Wait.
The evil part of the woods.
I don't get what's happening, but this is deeply unsettling.
They're gonna eat him.
Should I go join the wolves as well?
I love Shadow.
He's so cute.
No, you stay right here.
I'll fix this.
Again.
You can stay here with me.
And we can be alone together.
Aw, then you're not alone.
That's much better.
We have to go to the scary part of the forest.
Okay, first we'll go save that one.
We'll go help that one guy.
There's also the guy in the ice.
It's just so far away.
I think.
Actually, no.
He's not that far.
Maybe not that I think about it.
Oh my gosh.
This whole area.
Oh, they re-snowed it.
So it's so slow to get through.
Actually, we can go save him right now.
I think we're reaching the end.
I think so, too.
We don't have much...
There's no...
Besides the scary part, there's nothing else to explore.
So...
All the snow is back.
So it makes us really slow.
But here, I think if we slide down right here, he's like
right, um, doesn't he like right over here?
No.
He was screaming for help.
Over here?
Yes, over here.
We can get him.
Yeah, we still have a couple wood that we need to do, too.
Hello, I've come to save you.
Break ice.
Good thing I fixed my axe.
Oh, sorry, I skipped through it.
Gold.
Big.
Wee, wee.
Fire warm, wee, wee.
Big fire?
The great winter bonfire?
It will be magnificent.
I hope to see you there.
Oh, I'm fine.
Did I wait for an extra shot?
V-chan, welcome to...
To...
Thank you!
I'm hung...
Moomin is hungry for blood.
Alright.
Everybody, we saved that guy.
I feel much better.
Let's see, like, a friend of Nia.
The bottle, I never found the bottle in the message in a
bottle.
I wonder if it's in one of the ice things by the beach.
Hide and seek.
Oh, this guy must be in the scary woods now.
Snack for a stranger.
Oh, we can give that guy.
Okay.
Good memory.
I thought he was in the mountain.
Who else is left to save?
There's like one guy in the mountain.
I don't remember how to get to him, though.
I think it's right through here.
Wait.
Isn't this where I just went through?
The mountain base, yeah.
Okay, I don't know actually how to get to him.
I think he might be... I don't know.
Actually, I have no idea.
Sorry, it was gone.
Again!
I need to find him before he does something reckless.
Oh, it's up here.
a piece of the vase oh my gosh and then what do we have here
these pine cones have been frozen into a block of ice they
probably belong to the squirrel oh sad I hope they'll be
preserved until spring so that someone can enjoy them
check the map oh that's true it just says it doesn't really
show much though just says just says mountain base it
doesn't it's not very specific hmm he must have gone this
way
no his pine cone collection i think he'll i think he'll show
up to the bonfire and if not it's a terrible lesson for
children like not terrible you know what i mean but it's
like children sometimes things don't make it Sometimes
people leave you halfway through the wood.
His tracks lead up here.
You decide what's good.
No one is alone.
Truly, no one is alone.
I found this mushroom.
It's edible, I think.
Huh.
I use it in her cooking.
We, we, self-full.
We, we, self-we, we, happy, we.
Anyway, he doesn't, guys, he's not rude.
He just doesn't know please in our language.
That was a quick fix.
We, movement trolls, usually fill up on pine needles before
sleeping through the winter.
That always made me feel happy.
Oh.
We troll, we we strange.
This guy's a jerk.
I guess that's in the eye of the beholder.
I used to think you winter beings were strange, but then I
got to know you.
I love when you sing into the woods, blessed.
I love your profile picture.
Thank you.
Slightly regret.
Thank you so much for 23 months.
Almost two years.
Thank you so much.
Hmm.
now I realize we're just a bit different hmm different we we
good huh it really is we we take shard oh shard to make we
we happy we we we we I don't know about that but is that a
piece of movement mama's base you're right it does make me
happy yay another quest completed there's a there's this
area too I don't know how to get to it.
You see the ice and stuff there?
Hey, what are you doing?
Who are you?
We troll, we be strong.
Break the big eyes.
We're in this together.
Besides, I'm nothing without my tools or my friends.
Minto Red Letter Media collab win?
Never.
I don't want Mike to look at me of a shame.
Sorry, we went into the scariest part of the forest.
I better go look for him.
This game started scary.
Is it going to end scary?
We're going into the wolf clearing.
There we go.
Mike would shame himself.
Best of the worst featuring Minto.
Ooh, it's beautiful though.
Following the tracks.
Hmm.
So are you?
Where are you?
Oh, more wood.
Guys, we just need one more piece!
The one piece!
I think Mike only looks at Rich with shame though.
Pretty sure you'd be fine.
Help!
Oh!
Stay away from me!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
He just wants to join your path.
Help!
The wolves, my own kind, are turning against me!
Oh my gosh.
It's that serious.
You leave my friend alone.
You hear me?
Huh?
Stay close.
We'll get out of here together.
I'm too scared to move.
Make the wolves go away.
I've never scared it with anything in my life.
Except a squirrel.
My mistake.
What would two ticky do?
Should probably pack a hard snowball and chase them away.
All right.
A hard snowball.
You hear that?
Take that, wolf.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This ain't so bad.
I'm no wolf.
More like a sheep.
It looks like Scooby.
Scooby-Ooo.
Scooby-Doo.
What if the sheep won't have me either?
Understandable.
Look at you, so are you being saved again?
You don't deserve friends like this.
We'll figure it out later.
Right now, we need to get home.
No, I'm too scared.
Can't you carry me again?
Sorry you, you're a strong independent pooch.
You can do this.
Alright, I will follow you to the best of my ability.
But I'm really not a friend of the dark.
I will try to keep us in the light.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come.
To the next area.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come,
come, come.
Uh oh.
Scared of the dark.
Wait, I didn't know.
didn't get to read that uh what did it say what did I say oh
okay he has like a tolerance come on come on no worries
sorry you we've got this he will run away okay got it uh-huh
we're going we're going stay close stay close buddy whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm fast I'm you gotta be faster
boy oh is this a candle oh whoops wait sorry I pressed X
instead of Y I'm not going anywhere before those wolves are
gone easy
peasy straighten up I suck it You!
You!
Such a complainer!
Everybody here is!
Everybody in this dang valley is!
Bottom left is baby location?
What do you mean?
Uh-oh.
Okay, oh, we just gotta keep going.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, keep running, keep running.
I thought I was gonna blow us away, but we're not- We're
good, we're good.
Oh, that was a close one.
That was a close one.
This game really is Moomin becoming an adult.
He's brave enough to fight the wolves now.
I know, right?
It's so sweet.
Oh, no.
That looks like a lot of wind.
You're right.
We should seek cover behind the rocks.
Okay.
We run, we run.
Just follow me.
follow me is this behind a rock no keep going keep going
it's getting dark too dark okay we're good keep going i
know he grew up so fast he took on so many responsibilities
while nobody else would poor little guy he had to do so much
he woke up out of his out of his hibernation so scared and
And had to do all of this, all on his own.
Yeah.
Oh, geez, okay.
We're good.
I got the upgrade.
I'm still missing one.
Darkness surrounds me.
Missing one wood.
Oh, look at the stars, though.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Momintro!
Have you abandoned me?
I just slipped!
Not the first time.
Probably not the last.
He's so mature.
But I feel like I actually am this dog.
Don't worry though, use that plank to get over.
I'll keep the path lit with matches.
Oh.
Wait!
You have to get that!
That's my... That's the base for my mom!
We'll go back and get it.
We did it!
Great job!
Nice!
Alright.
How so?
That feels like me.
Uh...
Snowball.
And also I'm afraid, I'm so afraid of the dark too.
So I relate.
Hold on, you're the one who came over you.
Oh, uh oh.
That wolf is staring straight at me.
Make it go away and I'm intro.
Never ever ever ever ever ever ever ever.
Ever, ever, ever abandoned?
Ever, ever, ever, ever, ever?
Alright, let's go.
Oh, oops.
Ever, ever, ever, ever.
Boomin falls into a pit dog.
But what about me?
I know, it's so...
These characters are endearing and infuriating all at the
same time.
Hey, stop following me!
You need to go back to the...
You need to go back to the candle, buddy!
Oh my gosh, wait, stop!
You need to go to the candle!
I thought he would stay there because it's like the...
Oh my gosh, this takes so long.
It's like the little lamp that he's...
Come on, come on.
Take you back again.
Never ever reaper reaper?
Yeah.
Okay!
I'm holding you too then.
I think
we just gotta run through it.
Overcome your fear!
Oh, up here.
Overcome your fear of the dark!
Run!
Wait,
what am I supposed to do there?
Go behind the rock?
This right here?
I'm staying right here until those walls are locked.
Okay.
La la la.
The darkness.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're fine.
Come on, come on.
We don't have much time.
actually?
Oh, we'll wait for the next sec.
I mean, though, extra late tonight.
Yeah, it ended up being a lot longer, but I didn't think I
would finish the game today, but we're attempting.
Oh, he's still there.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is tough.
Yeah!
No!
Let's go, go.
Run, run, run!
We don't have much time.
I think we can hide here?
Please?
These dang woods segments.
This is the final boss of Moomin Gim, everybody.
This is the final boss.
You have to get through everything.
There we go.
Out of the woods.
Let's get you home.
Oh!
We beat him!
That was horrible.
I'm never coming back to nature again, ever.
Why does everybody at Moomin hate nature?
I offered my friendship to the wolves, but they rejected it
for real.
unknown harder than dark souls truly I might have a
potential friend for you waiting at the movement house
should be more your type really I feel 10 feet tall just
hearing about it make haste and carry me back no I'm not
carry I go also this dang dog finally just got over being
sick and then goes out into the cold frozen woods the cold
frozen dark woods The dog!
I mean, wolf!
They found him.
Fear me no more, for I am no longer a wolf.
I am a simple dog.
We're simply...
So are you.
Great.
Now I have to take care of three children and a dog.
Better than a wolf, I suppose.
I'll look after him.
I'll enjoy the company.
There's someone else eager to meet his new friend.
Dad is just honk-shoe in a way, or...
there you are oh shadow so cute a friend for me I was about
to say the very same so cute you were I think we'll get
along perfectly this is like kids in kindergarten they're
like are you a person me too let's be friends so what What
does it friends do?
Oh, I don't know.
Maybe we should give up.
No!
I know.
Do you want to play tag?
Are you an otaku too?
That is exactly what I want.
You're it!
Oh, they're so cute.
Oh my gosh, they're so cute.
No, you're it!
Wait, I just realized we didn't find that last guy.
He's still playing hide and seek.
I'm honored, but you can be it if you like tag.
It's so nice to see these two get along so well.
Thank you, Moon Mineral.
Troll.
Wait, Misabel's character art growth is, like, kind of
insane.
It's so awesome.
Can you keep an eye on them when I'm out and about?
I'd be delighted to.
Perhaps I could bring them both to the bonfire as well.
Moon Mineral.
I was about to ask you.
A bonfire?
we're in we will go as one that leaves one more guest i need
to find one more guest how about your best friend snuffkin
he's out on his adventures
no the one living in the back the bathing house oh too ticky
of course i will ask her i didn't even think of that thank
you Shadow, let's go outside and play.
Blisket.
It's alright with you, Mizzabelle.
Of course, but stay close to the Moomin House.
No more wolf packs are hiding around in caves.
I love the way Shadow goes.
So now we get to ask Tuteki.
Wait, I thought Tuteki, the bonfire was Tuteki's idea, no?
I assume Tuteki was already invited
what are they doing what is happening here oh hi momentum
troll we were building a snow fort to defend ourselves
against the lady of the cold except work turned out to be
more work than fun i'm not exactly pulling my weight here
perhaps you could help us her idea no invitation i'm really
focused on this bonfire project Yes, we're in except we're
not really on great terms at the moment.
Wait, what?
You guys were friends for five minutes.
Maybe we should go separately.
Let's just put a strain on our friendship.
These two should never go to IKEA together.
Wait, what?
Things that really haven't been the same for the last 15
minutes or possibly even longer.
Hmm.
I guess I can help out.
Looks like you're a few snowballs short.
Huh?
They're so...
They can't stand these children!
I know they haven't even known each other for 15 minutes.
Here, let's do the toughest one first.
Oh my god, there we go.
No, please, no, don't push it in there.
Yeah.
The controls on this are the worst part.
There we go.
Nice.
This is what it's like to be a kindergarten teacher.
It's solid.
Just like the snake.
Oh my goodness.
Anti-catermari.
It's true.
And we're so slow.
So why am I doing this part?
This is like...
Why did you leave holes in your floor is my question.
Oh shoot, I already messed it up though.
There we go.
I'm doing my best guys.
Local Moomin unable to say no to anyone.
Moomin has matured and grown up but he does not know how to
reject anything.
There, perfect right?
There's one thing missing.
I'll tear it apart.
Why did he say that?
We need to add a light.
There's only one problem.
Isabel doesn't allow us to play with fire.
All right.
Moomin troll, would you do the honor?
You're pretty handy with the matches, I reckon.
Of course I'll help you light it.
Thank you, Moomin troll.
This is perfect.
We should move in here permanently.
Spend all our winters and sunsets.
Summer's here.
No, you cannot do that.
Yes, let's start decorating it.
Do you have the peace?
Oh, I just remembered.
I forgot.
Oh, to give Moomin Troll something, something.
He did, in fact, warm our house.
Yes, we should give it to him instead.
Summer's in the snow fort.
Do you want to have this?
It's not much, but we've loved it dearly while it was in our
possession.
We hope it might bring you some joy as well.
A piece of the vase!
Yeah, thank you.
Now we can make snow lights without movement roll All right,
I'm out of here.
He is...
What?
No, that's not what I meant.
Shadow!
Me neither.
What a weird thing to say.
I love him.
Can you teach me...
Oh my god!
I think Shadow is like trying to read the room.
He's just like, yeah, movement troll is so annoying.
He's like, no, that's not what I meant.
He's like, oh, no, that's not what I meant.
I am.
Oh, God.
All right.
We're still one wood piece away.
Guys, I'm nervous.
Where do I find it?
I can't think of any more wood to chop.
Kitty?
Oh, hi there.
Mouse?
That is a cat.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Look of a worried mother.
I'd recognize...
That's a cat, no?
Am I crazy?
Is it that cave?
you're afraid about?
Are your children lost in the cave?
That looks like a cat.
I'm not usually one for caves, but if there's one thing I
like less, it's children not being with their mother.
Don't worry.
I'll get them for you.
Find the missing...
That's a mouse?
Why does it...
It moves its tail like a cat and everything.
Let's just pretend it's a cat.
It's a big fat rat.
Oh?
It looks like a cat too much.
I'm doing another side quest.
Maybe we can find some more wood, though.
That's what I'm hoping.
We'll go check down here first.
What did the rats look like?
I mean, the cats look like.
Okay.
Okay, nothing down here.
Hmm.
We can check in here.
Okay.
I'm getting sent on a wild mouse chase, for real.
Maybe a box it didn't break.
Maybe.
I have no idea.
I thought that there would be like a crazy space.
surplus of wood.
But I'm feeling the pressure now.
I'm feeling the pressure.
Are we looking for a rat, or a cat?
Both?
I don't know what they'll look like.
Maybe it's for the last quest.
Maybe.
I mean, there were some, like, plants that we hadn't beat
up.
They hadn't body slammed yet.
So, there is a potential of them being in there.
I think there was one time when you were body-slimbing a
bunch of snow bushes, like five or six together, there was a
piece of wood you missed.
No way.
I missed it?
Oh, no.
Where the heck is...
Why...
I'm almost through the entire cave, I feel.
I do want to go to bed.
I'm so tired.
I'm enjoying myself, but I have very tired.
Let's see.
And here?
We got that one, right?
I'm determined to finish.
Maybe there's some...
Maybe like this guy.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, I want my aim.
Maybe there's some here.
Maybe there's a piece of wood here.
Right, in this one.
Nope.
This one.
This is for sure the wood.
Nope.
I have not seen a single mouse.
Am I crazy?
There are no mice here.
Maybe.
I found one.
Huh.
Found you!
Squeak!
One out of three.
There's not three guys in him.
That leads to Moomin House.
This way?
But it was good.
We got to check those.
Oh, here's one.
There you are!
Squeak!
All right, that's two.
Where could the last one be?
I think there was one more room I didn't check.
The map also showed the cave.
The map is not helpful at all.
The map is quite unhelpful for indoor, or not indoor, but
inside locations.
I think I'm kind of going on a crazy chase.
I don't think I need to do this.
But I think they're just going to give me a base piece.
That's okay.
Like, I'm doing it for myself too.
Wild mouse chase.
I think it was...
What's this area?
Did we go this way?
Oh!
Why didn't I completely forgot about this?
Oh my gosh, we only have five vase pieces left.
That's crazy.
Oh wow, that's a good thing that we came back and explored
then.
I think we'll only get everything if we were to complete all
the missions.
Right now, I don't feel like running around so much.
Where the heck can this last guy be though?
And also, I don't remember where the exit is, that is like
the exit to the...
This is fine.
Whichever exit we take.
This is the only area I think I haven't...
Oh!
There we go.
Nice!
Don't worry!
Hurry back to your mother!
Squirt!
That's all of them.
They should go back to their mother.
Nice.
Luckily, I have an impeccable sense of direction.
And I know exactly where to go, I think.
I don't think she's going to give me wood.
I think she's going to give me a vase.
But we'll see.
We'll see.
Wait, uh...
The areas aren't so big.
I think the mountain is the worst area, and that's where we
have a couple...
Uh...
Or we have at least that one...
That one quest.
this guy and I have no idea
we could do the bottle one probably too because we'll be
over in this area I think actually I don't even know where
to find the bottle now I think about it he's gonna give you
cold hard cash here's a 50 on me buy yourself something nice
pretty face hmm hmm The wood!
No stinking way!
Oh my gosh!
Yeah!
How wonderful to see you back together!
For me?
Oh!
I guess that's a yes!
Thank you!
Three pieces of firewood, one for each mouse baby.
These will come in handy for sure!
Oh my god, the way they run is like crazy.
We have the amount of firewood.
Oh my god!
Run in with their whole body.
Hi, Tootikki.
There's something I forgot to ask you.
What do you need help with, Moomin, troll?
Nothing.
I'd like to invite you to the Great Winter Bonfire.
Oh, I thought I was already invited.
I thought so, too.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
So I wasn't before.
Oh, um, I...
I...
I'm just teasing you, movement troll.
I would love to come.
Everything's ready, isn't it?
Go to the bonfire.
Are you guys ready for the bonfire?
Let's go home.
Too thick is a real one.
For real.
I'm ready!
I'm ready for the bonfire!
I wish I could jump in the air.
Do an excitable roll.
It's time!
Oh my gosh, the mice saved us.
Yippee!
Woman's house.
Fire, fire, I like the fire.
There we go.
Wait, is there a fort gone?
No way.
The fort is gone.
What did I do all that work for, huh?
I think that song?
The fire, fire, like the fire.
That's my favorite.
Um...
Of...
They've been...
I feel like, uh...
Oh my gosh.
Why is my brain melting?
Melted from the bonsai fire.
Not Halloween.
Oh yeah, Advent song.
Advent song.
Have a good night, man.
The dream train just arrived.
Next stop is Dreamland.
By the way, there's a really cute girl with glasses in the
bottom left of the screen.
Couldn't look away.
She's so cute.
Good night, Marco.
Thank you.
Everybody's here.
imagine spring is just around the corner everything will be
like before spring the happiest time of the year supposedly
yes let's get rid of winter wait who's growling the wolves
are still growling let's get rid of winter once and for all
and the lady of the cold probably is other places to be i
kind of like her You're just too young to understand.
This game soundtrack and sound design are just so cozy.
They are.
I couldn't agree more with everybody.
Let's do this, Pac.
I've been ready for this task my whole life.
At least the last day or so.
Alone, I am brave.
But together, we are possibly even braver.
Seems like everyone is here except...
Snuffkin.
Ah, yes, our beloved music.
A once in a generation...
Oh, that's right.
I forgot about him.
A once in a generation talent.
I suggest we start.
No need to wait for her.
The wolf's growling.
Was that the avalanche?
What was that?
That sounded very much like an avalanche coming from the
mountains.
I called it.
I called it from the very beginning, you all.
You all heard me.
The emulence?
Looks like the problem took care of itself.
Oh my god, Philly Junk.
You, a man might have just died.
I have to go look for him.
I was the one that told him to go to the mountains in the
first place.
I feel so bad.
Hurry up and let's get this party started.
I have to go find him.
I cannot.
She's so evil, actually.
She's actually so evil.
One more quest.
Weeks are fine, weeks are fine.
No, it's okay.
Yeah, somebody is under an avalanche, probably suffocating.
And you're like, the trash took out itself.
Oh.
Oh, I thought, okay.
I thought it was worse than I thought.
I did not like the sound of that.
I better investigate where that crash came from.
The sound came from here.
Yeah, the mountain.
Oh, Laran.
Thank you so much for the raid.
Hello, everybody.
Hi.
I'm playing.
I'm playing movement.
So I go, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's cozy comfy time, except when everybody is trying to
kill each other.
Yeah, we might be able to do that other side quest if I can
figure out where it is.
Pursing glitch phase.
Thank you.
Snow is falling everywhere.
This path didn't used to be here.
Sounds like Hemulan's horn is coming from that direction.
Was there only one quest up in here?
There was a message in bottle.
I don't think we'll get to that.
The hide and seek guy.
Yeah.
I thought the guy that was needing help was over here, but
clearly not.
It's fine, it's fine.
Oh, there's something over here though.
What's this?
Oh, a piece of wood!
Thanks.
I gathered wood.
It doesn't even tell me how much I have.
Uh...
Do I go this way?
Oh, yeah, I do.
I gotta go this way, yeah.
Happy time!
Cozy, cozy hours here.
Stop playing it!
That sounded like another avalanche.
And then...
And the hemulin is stopped playing.
I don't like this at all.
Uh-oh.
Hemulin!
Where are you?
Oh my.
What has happened?
There's so much snow.
Oh my gosh.
Do we have to dig our way all the way up?
Amuland?
Are you there?
He could be anywhere.
How will I ever find him?
This is impossible.
I don't even know where to start.
Nothing is impossible.
Believe in yourself.
Everybody's here!
Not everybody.
Missabel!
And Scooby-Doo!
And Shadow!
I didn't even think you liked the emulon.
It's like you said, we're all family.
Did I say that?
Well, I've certainly felt it.
Almost everybody.
Nobody in my pack gets left behind.
Although, this would be a good time to abandon my
principles, as this task seems rather difficult.
Come on, so are you.
If anybody can find him, it's you.
Yeah, you as your big schnauz.
that's a lot of pressure hey you believed in me now's my
time to believe in you it's like such a shifty laugh I'm
starting to believe in myself I shouldn't you never forget
you are sorry you I'm sorry you the leader of our pack after
Mizzabelle, of course.
So cute.
Oh my gosh, that's a real avalanche.
This way!
Snip, snip.
No, this way, obviously.
Colder.
But that's just my nose.
The trail is getting warmer.
He's here!
I'm 30% sure!
Could be high.
higher odds but we were at 0% before so that's almost 40%
let's go I'll start digging flash
it'll save every one of us the rhythmic thumping of the
flash corny what oh oh in my way oh in my way oh it's like a
little maze at the same time I'm digging but it's also a
maze I'm digging but it's also a maze.
Yeah, that's a better than gotcha luck, so true.
Oh, maybe the way he went was kind of like a clue.
Because he kind of zigzagged along.
He's here, help me!
Wait, he is?
Did I get to him?
Oh!
KFP bus driver will come back
I thought I was done for I never stopped believing in you
for a second except that first part oh moment troll I must
thank you ha don't thank me thanks are you, Shadow and
Missabel yes yes thank you so much for saving my life even
though Woman Valley truly wouldn't be the same without you
Come on, we've got a bonfire to attend Oh Unfortunately, I
seem to have lost my skis and my horn I guess You won't be
missing my horn There will be no party without it Let's find
it I was over here playing when the avalanche took me My
items must have been taken Further down the mountainside
Let's go Oh Okay, we gotta find his... Why do we... Why are
the skis necessary?
Are the skis part of the bonfire?
So heartwarming.
I know, right?
So sweet.
If only there was a way to get out over there.
I'll see what I can do.
The friendly neighborhood in Moomin.
Hiya!
Oh, whoops.
Oh, yeah.
Everybody's so fast.
Oh, they're designers.
Those skis.
Yeah, they're very important.
You don't understand.
I did the most amazing split in an attempt to jump over the
avalanche.
My skis, sadly, couldn't keep up.
Oh.
One of them landed over there.
My other stuff must be laying around here somewhere as well.
Everybody start digging.
With your hands.
I'm pretty good at finding stuff.
I'll just pretend I'm tidying up after the avalanche.
And I'm pretty good at helping Miesabel.
Everybody has known each other for a day.
Have you thought about that?
And I'm like the perfect assistant to saw you.
We got this team.
So see life.
Alright, we got this team.
Nobody does anything.
Nobody moves.
man
Lumen troll to the rescue
But I'm tired of digging back in my day I shut I shoveled
every snow in the world That's how I got to school every day
I'm here to help again Good what are you gonna do?
Oh, he's gonna sniff the ski.
Maybe?
Sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff, sniff,
sniff, sniff, sniff, cough, sniff, sniff, cough, sniff,
sniff, cough, sniff, sniff, cough, sniff, sniff, cough,
sniff, sniff.
Great!
You found it!
You kind of had to go around, though.
Yeah.
Where?
Oh, here.
Oh, that's the ski.
Okay.
Here's one ski.
I'm on fire.
Did it say it's not worth much?
So they're not even that valuable?
Wait, what is this?
Is this the axe?
Nope, just some ice.
Am I going down this way?
Yeah, okay.
Sentimental value.
They're priceless.
Yeah, you're so right.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to doubt your Didn't mean to doubt it.
Woman is crazy strong.
For the sake of...
Oh, why do you have to go to the other side, woman?
How the heck did you guys get down there?
She wasn't kidding when she said she'd clean up.
Oh, it's in a bush.
I think I saw something shiny in one of these bushes.
Mm-hmm.
Which one?
Hmm.
I'm not sure.
It was only a glimpse.
You'll have to check.
No worries.
This is my specialty.
The body slant.
Oh!
I think I found it.
Hold on.
I'm gonna see if there's any like vase pieces in here.
Though I don't think we'll complete it at all.
Ah, whatever.
Here.
Let's just get it.
Hello and welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I don't remember where I saw it.
It was that one.
Yes.
Huh.
I sure was, Ms. Bell.
Alright, just one ski left.
Stealth drop mode.
Loud horn.
Some say it's not the horn, which is loud.
I think it's about the user, maybe?
Alright.
We just gotta get this ski.
Then we gotta get home.
And then we gotta bonfire.
And then we can see the Aurora Borealis and go to sleep and
go and bring the...
wait until spring all we gotta do is wait until spring this
game has made me feel cooler though anybody else it's so icy
hey shadow one of the skis must be somewhere under the snow
here did I try to locate it please please I've seen how
sorry you does it I know exactly what to do but do you have
the nose for it.
Sounds great, give it a try.
You can do a shadow!
Whoa!
Wait, this one's long.
Okay.
Woof!
Did you find it?
Wait, did he find it or not?
Uh, we didn't even say anything.
We did not humor him at all.
We're like, okay.
Oh my god, he wasn't kidding when the rocks were like, all
the way like this.
Okay, maybe we can just go do this.
Nice.
We found it.
Yes, we did.
My powers of smell are increasing.
Also, my ability to smell.
And right now, I smell.
The Hemulin and the others.
They're at the end of the cave.
Come on.
Reminding me of the mine scene in the MGS.
That's what I was thinking, too.
That should be everything.
Yeah, it reminds me of the mine part in MGS 1-2 also.
Where she, like, walks along it.
I just run through it every time.
everybody oh there you are that's it here you are skis and
your horn thank you all of you
no thanks needed now are you coming to the bonfire if you'll
still have me
oh quick travel please that'd be awesome we go to the
bonfire I actually don't know my way back so I think it's
loading it's big loading a big fire the big the biggest
bonfire ever I want to see the lady of the cold wait it's
still loading oh the hamulet I mean the a hemmulant.
Seems like we're ready.
Moment troll.
Light it up.
Strike a match to light the bonfire.
Here we go!
Am I really ready for this?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Oh!
Everybody's dancing!
Everybody's got the moose!
It looks warmer, it looks greener.
I feel warm and wonderful.
Spring must be approaching.
Or maybe it's the fact that you finally let loose and
enjoyed yourself.
I know I should go to bed, but I just don't want to yet.
That's the most reasonable thing you've said all winter.
Enjoy the party.
Talk to some friends.
We're even better.
Let's have a snowball fight.
That'll cool you down.
Oh
my, I was thinking about that snowball match.
Perhaps we could not do it.
Way ahead of you.
Seems like I won this winter.
Well, there she goes.
We have to say goodnight to everybody, all of our friends.
Oh, never mind.
We don't say go...
Huh.
So what are you two going to do now that spring is around
the corner?
Uh-huh.
Well, first I have to get my horn back down from the tree.
How did it get up there?
What is with everyone getting things stuck in the trees?
Oh.
Mizzabelle dared me.
Tee-hee.
I like Mizzabelle.
Did you just prank the amulet?
What?
The girl can't have any fun.
The Mizabell growth has been the best thing ever.
What would you even do without me?
Let me see if I can get it down.
Oh.
Where is it even?
There it is.
She's so fun, yeah.
There you go.
Thanks a lot, Moomin Troll.
Yes, thanks a lot.
Finally, we can enjoy some peaceful horn music again.
If I didn't know any better, I'd swear you were being
sarcastic.
Oh no, he's actually doing it.
You didn't even see me coming.
I kind of don't want to talk to her.
I just thought I'd say goodbye.
Leaving so soon, come join us when we're playing hide and
seek.
You're letting your children brown in the forest?
Oh yes, I'm not worried.
and friendly beings.
Oh.
I've worried so much lately that I feel all worried out for
the moment being.
Maybe you should take a break yourself.
Come find us.
Look away while we hide.
Ready or not, you're right.
Oh, oh, I see one.
I see one.
I got you.
There you are.
Let them hide forever.
How are you feeling?
Still full?
Today full.
Today, happy.
Thank you
for tonight, Momentrol.
That was the best party I've ever been to.
Come to think of it, it was probably the only party I've
ever been to.
Are they all like this?
Huh.
I can't say that I'm a bad experience myself, but I think
this was special.
Hmm.
I think so, too.
Shadow and Sawryu really needed this.
Huh.
I think we all did.
Even though this might be the only bonfire party we'll have,
I'll cherish this memory.
right supposedly it's been happening for a thousand years so
i see no reason for this to be being the last one same time
next year then same time next year i wouldn't miss it for
the world oh my gosh i could talk to all these guys too
troll strong troll break ice huh we're in oh yeah okay uh
the these guys are all the same conversations.
My ancestor!
Wonderful festivities, right?
He's sleepy!
I'll take that as a yes.
Thanks for joining me in the celebrations!
No, thank you.
That was the greatest celebration I've ever been to!
Just like me.
Not me.
I've been to perhaps a dozen parties wackier than this.
Wild times.
Okay, shadow.
That's a bit unlike you to say.
Don't worry.
He kind of lost himself during the party.
I think I actually found myself.
Seeing how all your shadows followed your every dance moves
I got to thinking, maybe I should try doing my own stuff.
So I experimented with some moves myself.
Would you know, some of the guests even copied me.
Imagine the fools.
Take it easy.
Sorry, this is new to me.
I'll probably snap out of it soon.
The horn.
I've been thinking of getting a girlfriend.
I'm game.
We should join forces.
It would double our chances of getting one.
Maybe we should get one each?
Sounds like a lot of hassle Maybe we should just stick with
Misabel She's more like a mother figure Yes I know Misabel
is great She is She is the best person I know Next to you
Maybe she could a boyfriend for her She deserves one Oh my
gosh, what is this conversation?
Or even better.
Oh, girlfriend!
Now we're talking!
Girlfriend for Missabel!
I wonder how this looked a thousand years ago.
Probably just the same as now.
It's comforting to know that some things never change.
These writers are cool.
We did it too, Tiki!
We lit the great winter bonfire!
What a celebration it was.
I'm so glad it's done.
It was so much work.
It actually was.
Six hours later.
You brought warmth wear where there was none.
Menuri real?
Happy pride.
Look at everyone celebrating together.
You should feel proud of yourself.
Something has definitely changed.
I can feel it.
Is it spring?
Hmm.
Or perhaps it's a you that is changing.
What did we sacrifice?
Let me check, huh?
No, I'm still the same old movement troll.
I feel very excited though.
I don't think I'll be able to go to bed yet.
You should join your friends.
Nights like these don't come around often.
Maybe one day you'll be looking back at this night.
Okay, please shut up.
Shut up.
I should have gotten her first, but I was trying to get him.
Sounds like big dream.
You lot seem to like the...
Listen to this.
They like music.
Big gooey wooey music.
Yes, it's not bad if I say so myself.
Good night, my friends!
Where are we playing hide-and-seek with some of these guys?
Oh, here's another one.
I should probably find them before I...
Hmm.
Good hiding place, but not good enough.
Uh...
Let's find the...
Oh, here's mom.
Got you!
Do you guys see the last guy?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I didn't even see him.
here.
Haha, got you!
Okay, little my, you win, I'm defeated.
There's a small path on the east.
Bottom, right?
There's tracks in the snow.
Oh, this here.
Nice eye, guys.
Oh, there's even more guys down here.
Oh, I think he's hiding in the snow.
That would make sense.
What is this?
Oh, wood.
Found you!
Sneaky fella.
Could you say Little Maya is an Ocelot to movement snake?
Maybe.
It's a great way to think of it though.
The music is so cute.
Goodbye everybody.
I guess I never thanked you for helping us so much this
winter, Mumen Troll.
Yeah, you didn't.
You did in your own way.
No, you should say it with your words, too.
I hope you get to play hide-and-seek with your own mother
soon.
You have no idea how much I want to.
You've been taking care of everyone's problems, Mumen Troll.
It's your turn to be carefree now, within reason, of course.
They've acknowledged our hard work.
So who throws the meanest snow?
all around.
You do, little my.
You do.
Two could play at this game.
Wait, I could just throw it at this guy?
Ouch, cold.
I'm sorry.
Wait, why can I only hit the forest creatures?
Oh, I can Oh, stop.
Good throw.
Oh, he's still going.
It was just standing there.
Can you throw it still while it's in the tuba?
I'm trying.
I could leave now.
Or I could stay for a bit.
This may, after all, be my last winter bonfire celebration.
Good night, friends.
I think we stayed enough.
See you at home.
Or in spring.
Last ever?
Last for the year, right?
I mean, there only do one a year, no?
That's that!
Time to go to bed now.
It was so scary when we first started the game.
I don't know if I'll be able to sleep, though.
Mm-hmm.
It'll probably do me good just to lie down a bit and...
Ah.
Zzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzzz.
A snorer!
Huh.
What a night.
Almost unreal.
And best of all, winter is gone!
Huh.
First I will smell the flowers.
No!
I'll go fishing!
Or maybe just lay in the grass.
Oh!
Wait, what is this?
This is worse than before!
Winter storms and frost.
This was not the deal.
To Tiki promised spring would be back.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
There's more?
I can't believe this.
To Tiki clearly said it.
one piece
I'm I've done everything I could and more and winter is
still here hmm Tewtiki has a lot to answer for Tewtiki is
not the weatherman time for some movement revenge oh my god
time for some new game plays oh
I'm...
Is Tootiky lying to me the whole time?
Why is this... Why did they choose to go with this ending?
Why didn't Moomin just fall asleep and...
That could be the end of the game.
Tootiky, you owe me an explanation.
Why are you so mad at Tootiky?
Snow, snow, and even more snow!
I'm sick and tired of the stupid winter in Tootiky as well!
Why are we getting like this at Tootiky?
Why did I have to do so much for nothing?
That's how I feel right now.
She's so mad.
I thought Tuteki knew what she was talking about.
Moving this spot of rampage.
Tuteki isn't here.
Figures.
Easy now.
That's right.
Tuteki?
Wait.
This might be the best ending.
Tewtiki, what are you doing?
Moment troll, be careful.
The ice is breaking.
Oh my god.
The soil!
What?
Yeah, where's the water?
Ouch.
What's this?
Where am I?
Am I dead?
Or in the Lady of the Cold's realm?
What is happening?
Hold tight, movement troll!
I'll come back to save you!
Somehow.
Yes, we've got your back!
Tootiki!
Squirrel!
Hold on tight!
I suspect I will do the rescuing from here on.
Save Tootiki and the Squirrel.
I'm sort of in disbelief at the moment.
What?
Too ticky!
Oh my freaking god.
So cold.
Oh, I see them.
Wait, do I have to wait until they block the wind?
How is this still happening?
How is this game still going?
Does the wind stop?
How am I supposed to snowball?
There's no way...
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
I miss the icicle atop, sorry.
No way this is still going.
Oh wait.
Oh, no.
I'm in a dinner reminder.
Yeah, I'll have it eventually, I guess.
I didn't pack it all today.
Or rather, I did.
I didn't pack it all tonight.
It's dark.
It's dark, it's scary.
To the key!
Oh!
What the heck?
Dobby?
Why was Dobby in the cave?
I don't understand why the game didn't end.
Most people wouldn't complain.
I'm just confused.
Mostly.
I love movement.
I'm just like, what is happening?
3 a.m.
dinner.
Yeah, maybe.
I might have to adjust my schedule tomorrow, guys, if that's
okay.
Maybe I pushed Deadly Premonition to another day.
Do something shorter tomorrow.
I didn't expect this.
I also thought that this would maybe be...
A voiced.
I didn't expect to have to voice the entire thing.
Oh my god.
Wait, this is actually torture for me.
final boss for real oh
no i need you here got
this baby gib in
the water though she's like soaking wet she's gonna die
hypothermia for real well done friends we're trying to oh
gosh this bridge seems unstable but it's the only way
Believe in yourself, Momentroll.
Will others seem to?
Don't give up.
We lost all our stuff.
Oh no, Moments.
Oh, my tools.
Lost in the water.
How am I supposed to manage without them?
With only myself to rely on... Wait, those were not our
things.
Snap out of that Momentroll.
Too ticky and the squirrel needs you.
Help!
There you are, I'm coming!
I'm running as fast as I can.
I have a really pudgy body.
Oh my goodness.
Well, I have to follow this dang thing.
Oh shoot, wait.
Oh, guys.
No.
Guys?
Do you think if I close out of the game?
Is there a save?
Do you think if I close out of the game, I've restarted?
I need the closure.
Wind said sleep.
No!
Also, shut up.
Whoever said something.
Shut up, Steiner!
Oh, I need a button to continue.
Continue.
Guys, we can do this.
Oh no, okay, okay, we can move!
We're moving, we're moving!
We're moving, we're
moving!
First try.
We're moving.
Wind slows me down.
I should dash while the ice is...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, Vaxe.
Good job.
This is a big boy.
Alright, we're almost there!
Yeah!
We're moving!
Oh wait, I don't have my...
I don't have my matches.
Oh geez.
This way?
Up and around?
We're moving.
It can't be that difficult of an area because they know
they're you have no lie.
Right?
They wouldn't make it that tough.
Oh, a dead end.
Yeah!
Wait, is this the same area as before?
I think?
We're moving!
Seems like the same area as before.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Why did...
I thought it would be shorter than I saw it.
Or rather.
Yeah, oh wait, does this have two?
Oh, that was so close, holy cow.
Oh, it's just the, it's just like this again before.
Okay, alright.
Final boss, guys!
We can go!
Can't move me!
Tooteki Squio, come here!
It's too risky.
The ice will cave.
Go back a moment, Troll.
You can still get out.
Hogwash.
I'm coming for you!
Moving, Troll!
You fool!
There's still time to turn back!
I was too fast.
The Squoil!
That was very brave!
Hmm.
And reckless.
Here, let me help you out.
Oh my god, they're on the tip of a- they're on the edge of a
waterfall.
Don't slip.
Oh my gosh!
The high stakes!
Too ticky or shivering!
It would seem the Lady of the Cold has gotten the best of
me.
a fire.
But we don't have any matches.
I found some firewood in the water.
Pretty small, though.
Oh, I forgot.
I don't have any matches.
Then you'll have no use for this scrappy little piece of
wood.
Squail, is that?
One of my matches?
You genius!
Would you believe no one has ever called me that before?
Oh my gosh, I can't believe this guy survived.
The closure, the squirrel looved.
Here it goes.
What's wrong?
Is it too wet?
So, what do we do now?
We warm ourselves.
Do you see a way out?
No.
But?
this is how the game ends we are together that we are let's
do campfire stories anyone okay i'll go first this one time
i was fleeing
side so i threw myself down luckily i grabbed the brain
another bear yikes at the top of it all off i was surrounded
by bees honeybees from behind on my branch know where to go
so what did you do I don't remember.
Oh yes, I do.
I tasted honey.
It tasted fantastic.
I like that story.
Me too.
That sounds like Hemulin.
Here, we're here.
That's the two found you.
No way.
That's actually everybody.
Oh my god.
She's in her little makeover outfit.
Love a little mime.
You're like, Poole!
You all came for us.
As did you.
For all of us.
Look at her.
She's beautiful.
The Lady of the Cold?
I suppose she is.
But aren't you upset?
She almost tried to kill you.
Yet she didn't.
Well, there is that.
But you must miss summer, right?
Oh.
Oh, I do love summer.
As I love winter.
It is simply a different kind of love.
Huh.
This looks almost unreal.
I'm gonna go see the Aurora Borealis one day and think about
the time I almost died.
You can't tell if it really does exist or if it just looks
like existing.
All things are very uncertain.
That's exactly what makes me feel reassured.
You can see Aurora Borealis.
Actually, we were supposed to have like a crazy geometric
storm this weekend.
I get it.
Or I'm not sure I do, but I think I like it.
And you, Squail?
Are you the same Squail from before?
Who knows?
Meings come and go.
You all look the same to me.
All I know is that I'm mean and that I'm here now.
Hmm.
Maybe she is here to stay.
The lady.
Guess she's not so bad after all.
We got to see the Aurora!
The Lady of the Cold is not that scary.
Really?
Once you get to know her.
I don't know how I would have managed without my friends
though.
I should go talk to them.
Seems like some of them are leaving.
Say goodbye to everyone.
We'll save Little Mai for last.
Oh, the ancestor is in the bed.
I'm sorry if things got a bit loud there for a minute.
Not at all.
I would choose your horn over the sound of an empty house
anytime.
Goodbye's part two.
Yeah, I thought we said goodbye at the bonfire.
It was rather great at the festivities, wasn't it?
Anyway, I'll be moving on soon.
Who knows how long winter is here.
I don't want to enjoy it as much as possible before it goes
away.
Break a leg!
Or even better.
Don't!
Oh, he's actually leaving!
Mama, my beautiful vase.
Uh-oh.
We didn't complete it.
It's nice with family around.
Good night, ancestor.
Get out of my house.
Good night, Mito.
Good night.
I'm not usually one for adventures, but this was rather
remarkable.
Filly Junk, I still...
I still don't forgive you.
My children seem to have developed an appetite for danger,
though.
Oh, God.
Which I guess is good in moderation.
If it makes them more resilient, I don't have to worry so
much.
Speaking of, I think we're ready to move home now.
Thank you for your hospitality.
Sangier made Winter feel less scary.
She has improved a lot.
You made it less scary for me as well.
Thank you, Philly Junk.
Go Junkle somewhere else.
us any time.
The children need their fun friend of Moo Mint Roll.
Moo Mint Roll around.
Bye!
What will you two be doing now?
Moo Mint Roll.
After some soul searching, we found our true calling.
It took us hours.
At least it felt like it.
But it was worth it.
We're hard-boiled detectives now.
We've already solved our first case.
I'm obsessed with how stupid these two are the case of the
missing last cookie it was shadow who ate it yes i'm so
furious right now but also relieved that we could put that
case to rest oh we're already up to our next case the case
of who wet my bed last night that was probably me as well
shadow
That's two cases down We're unstoppable Have you ever in
trouble?
Just contact us We've got your back Movement Valley feels
safer with you I don't know about that movement Don't lie to
them They're actually so stupid They're so funny They're so
funny.
Thank you for everything, Mumen troll.
Are you feeling better, Missy Belle?
Oh, yes.
This winter has been quite the adventure.
And taking care of those two troublemakers brought me out of
my own head for a bit.
I needed that.
I know the feeling.
What will you be doing now?
I've been thinking of moving in with my sister.
I suspect she's lonely.
didn't she just get engaged that sounds wonderful I'll miss
you though much like the seasons I'll be coming around
oh little my now that I've mastered the art of skiing and
sledding I guess a moon moon and mama can have her tree back
Isabelle doesn't seem to be needing it anymore either I
guess the makeover worked or something huh that would be
wonderful what are your Plans!
Plans only lead to disappointment.
Let's see what happens.
I'm thinking of sticking around a bit, though.
It'll look like you can need some company.
I would like that, little boy.
Time for bed.
A new day waits tomorrow.
My goodness.
Ow!
Do we need the...
Do we need the snoring?
Yay!
Everybody lived!
I'm ready for until dawn too.
That was the best sleep I've had in years.
Hi, sleepyhead.
Taking your sweet time, are you?
It's time for breakfast!
Oh, I'll get right on it, little Mai.
Oh, saying goodbye.
Enjoy breakfast.
Is everybody awake now?
Good morning, Moomin, Mama and Moomin, Papa.
They are!
Spring is here for real!
Pancakes!
Good morning, Moomin, Troll.
Hello, darling, son.
Breakfast is just ready.
Moomin, Mama, Moomin, Papa, Papa!
Hi!
You slept so well we didn't want to wake you.
Oh, by the way.
There's someone outside waiting for you.
Oh!
Huh.
Stop, kid!
Ah!
Stop kid!
Stuffkin is so cool!
Oh, look at them!
Oh, so cute!
She's like, yeah!
Oh, so sweet!
That was so sweet!
Now I'll go to the side now, I'll go back here.
Oh no, she's putting her vase back together!
Oh, so sweet!
guys enjoyed it oh that ended up being much longer than i
expected to i thought i would i thought i would do it in two
parts but i got too into it and then by the time i felt like
it was a good time to stop i was like oh well i'm too far in
congrats on woman happy six seven you mean june 7th yeah
woman troller will return in woman ending four
Yeah!
He's a good chopper now!
Oh, so sweet.
Can I read those things with a long, comfy stream?
Hope you're feeling a little better.
I'm okay.
I mean, I'll be okay.
Oh, look at them.
Yeah, they're so stupid.
Oh, no.
They're so stupid.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Thanks for the shoppingly epic stream.
Most cute, popular celebrity.
Oh, they meet, they're meeting.
They're friends.
It was super cozy and fun after a long week.
Now go eat, sleep well.
Yeah, warm and happy dreams of kissy squirrels.
Oh yeah.
The squirrel.
I can't believe he's lived.
It is his dad, isn't it?
The ancestor.
Oh, the puppies.
Boo!
Oh my gosh, a cat named Boo!
So cute!
You're my snuffkin to my Mumen troll.
Thank you.
I don't want to skip the credits, but there's no more music.
They didn't have a loop.
They didn't have the music loop.
I will go
eat now.
I think I'll change stream for tomorrow.
We'll push, like, deadly premonition to maybe...
Oh, wait.
When can I do deadly premonition?
Maybe I could still do it.
I don't know.
Ask Dak.
I just...
I have to take off Monday because I need a full day to pack.
Actually, I don't remember what my schedule is that I wrote
up this next week.
Oops.
I'll figure it out.
Otsumitsu, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I might not have a schedule next week because it will kind
of depend on how much I pack and I move next week even,
so...
I have to finish packing and I move completely next...
Well, actually, I guess it's Sunday.
I move this week, so...
Yeah, probably no schedule.
But I do have things planned.
Thank you so much, everybody.
um yeah
good luck good working good luck boss we're at your back
thank you thanks for the long stream we love you thank you
thank you thank you
i'm just gonna end it here not even an ending screen good
night everybody bye bye bye bye bye i'll let you listen to
the music him and I'll end the stream.
Bye!